hello everybody I didn't know if I was
actually going to make it today I was
planning on streaming a good Friday I've
read it's Good Friday I don't know
anything about it as many of you know
I'm Jewish but I read that it's Good
Friday and so they're doing an earlier
press conference today I was planning on
streaming then I got stuck at Trader
Joe's and I put a little video of this
on an Instagram story they are limiting
the number of people in Trader Joe's so
there was this huge socially distance
line all around the parking lot which I
was in and I they handed out free gummy
bears which was the upside but I ended
up always almost missing today's stream
and press conference altogether so
fortunately fortunately I was able to
make it now I think I need to adjust our
super chat graphic it looks like it's a
little bit off-center but I guess we
won't know until super chats start
coming in so we're here Donald Trump
yesterday sort of teasing some big
announcements at today's press briefing
but I don't really know what they would
be I didn't cut my hair no it's just I
haven't gone running or anything so
usually the 5:00 p.m. press conferences
I've gone running and you know if I've
become windblown but it has not happened
today there has been no haircut
whatsoever it's just kind of under
control but you know just a little bit
of wind and then things get very very
crazy as you can see this thing over
here so we are standing by this was
scheduled for 1 p.m.
luckily since they're late all the time
I made it I made it and I'm gonna be
able to do the do the press conference
with you guys welcome if you're watching
on YouTube Twitter twitch or Facebook
live and we are wondering what the big
news is going to be today one thing a
few of my friends have been asking me is
do as as if I know but people think I
know stuff I really don't do I think
schools are going to open in the fall I
believe if I had the bet and I don't I
don't bet on stuff my guess would be
that they will open schools in the fall
elementary schools and high schools but
November there will will probably start
to be a second wave and I don't know
that we will get through the fall
semester with schools open that would be
my guess and again I have no special
knowledge of that in any way it's just
kind of one one if you said what do I
think is the most likely scenario what
is there a plurality chance of I would
say school does open in the fall but we
end up having wave two during that
during that fall semester people
wondering what's going on with the
timing this was scheduled for 1 p.m.
meaning 26 minutes ago and it has not
yet started so it was delayed and as a
result we're all here and it's extremely
exciting as you can all tell Haggar Ian
says ok so I think I think I'm gonna be
able to fix the super chat thing I've
got that and then I bring it over and
then expand it a little I think that's
what we need there we go ok hey gar Ian
says via super chat apparently this is a
big day for Q D equals 4 J equals 10 T
equals 20 which is today's date they
think something big will be revealed
what is that is this like conspiracy
stuff Zachary Monroe says since I hate
Trump I'll go for Biden we've got to get
rid of the wannabe authoritarian
hopefully the 47th presidential election
will go better last SC for now love for
the Pakman yeah you know yesterday I
actually watched John McCain's
concession speech in 2008 and Barack
Obama's victory speech in 2008 and it's
like you know I didn't like John McCain
and Obama it was not as progressive as I
would have wanted but my how we've seen
the discourse degrade over the last many
many years it's it's really crazy white
death says have you considered
interviewing Mena activists I have not
bulkier writer says if I got a dollar
every time you talked about your hair
I'd be richer than Jeff Bezos Charlie
says extremely shocked that the press
conference is starting late what gives
yeah who knows Mary Allen says when can
we expect a man bun it's gonna be a
while it's nowhere near long enough for
that Dave Matthews says it seems like
you're in favor
Bill Clinton's triangle strategy more
and more can you comment on this no I
that I've not mentioned anything like
that and I I do not believe that that is
the case okay let's get the latest
updated numbers the official number of
coronavirus cases globally is
approaching 1.7 million and we have
tragically surpassed 100,000 deaths we
are number one here in the United States
with three times the number of cases of
any other country known cases remember
we are not testing that much many
countries are testing much much more we
are seeing some improvements in terms of
the rate of growth so we are at almost
500,000 cases almost 18,000 deaths but
if we look at the trend lines you see
that we sort of have plateaued so now we
are we you know I explained to to folks
that the peak is really a it's a phase
it's a plateau we sort of have been
there since April 3rd so we're actually
like a we said we appear to be a week
into the plateau let's hope that that's
the case and it's not a temporary
leveling before it goes up and we've got
to maintain social distancing in terms
of deaths we have had three big days
right around 2000 deaths with small
declines during each of the three again
the hope is it's insane that we're
saying hey great news we're not going
beyond 2,000 deaths a day
it feels insane to be saying that but
hopefully these numbers don't continue
to grow and we'll have a sense of that
you know in in a few hours and quite
quite a few hours I guess I would say
unfortunately we're already at 1,300
deaths today and we're only halfway
through the day so that does not bode
particularly well lastly the kovat 19
projections from IH Emme have still not
been updated since April 8th
so our instinct is that if this were
updated it would look different but it
still is saying that we are peaking on
April 12 and again
April 12 peak would be a period of
peaking that goes all the way back to
earlier in the month and it would
probably last through the end of the
month realistically total number of
deaths still expected to be 60,000 for15
Chris Hayes from MSNBC has been getting
crushed because he suggested that the
Trump administration may have floated
let's get into HD we want full HD here
oh they only go to 720p Chris Hayes
suggested that the Trump administration
floated a higher number to then claim
victory over a lower number and a bunch
of people went after him saying that's
so incredible that's so offensive for
Chris Hayes to say I don't watch Chris
Hayes I've never I've not seen his show
for a couple years but it seems very
likely to me that that is something the
Trump administration would do they would
say hey look this is the number we
should all be scared of and then when we
get a lower number they claim victory
and in fact Trump is doing it Trump now
has started to say listen if we did
nothing we would have had 2 million
deaths so hundred thousand it's bad but
it's much better and you can thank me
for that
what world leader would do nothing right
like no world leader is doing nothing so
this idea of 2 million and anything
below that is thanks to Trump you know
the I was just I'll put in another plug
I was just at Michael's deli in
Brookline picking up some corned beef
and knishes and all of this stuff Steve
from from Michaels deli wouldn't have
done nothing like Steve my point is any
business owner anybody with any kind of
experience in almost any field would
have gotten us below 2.2 million deaths
so for Trump to take credit and say he
won because where he did something seems
extremely it's not just dishonest it's
it's ridiculous quite frankly but anyway
that is certainly what they are doing
that is the strategy that they are
putting in place which is saying listen
if we get with 260k it's only thanks to
us and anyway I think you guys kind of
understand what the what what the
analysis is there okay let's just do a
quick check of Donald Trump's Twitter
to see what he's been posting lately
posting a video about Easter okay
posting a video about Burnie and Warren
retweeting that lunatic trish regan
who's been fired from fox news for
saying the entire coronavirus thing is a
fake retweeting tom Fitton an absolute
lunatic from judicial watch so
essentially a normal day a normal day on
Trump's Twitter the invisible enemy will
soon be in full retreat talking about TV
ratings for his briefings announcing
that there will be a 1 p.m. press
briefing today we are of course half an
hour past that already so that's where
we are right now ladies and gentlemen
and it's all it's all looking pretty
ugly but fortunately if we have to find
some good news we can say they're
starting to be a decline in the rate of
growth in cases okay I'm gonna play
something for you I did this very late
in yesterday's stream so I want to play
it for people today I got a voicemail
yesterday from a concerned neighbor
claiming to check in on me and check out
who it was that gave me a call take a
listen to this now at this point I
haven't lived in North Hampton for like
eight years so I already figured it's
off of some outdated list I was hearing
helped me notice they never mentioned my
name either program and I hope you um
you can find some comfort for yourself
so again it's so that's just to hope as
witnesses JW there's nothing special
there's no Bible documents relevant to
staying home and all it's just though
Jehovah's Witnesses website
and I hope you in your household are
doing well and there you go
can you imagine calling a cultural and
ethnic Jew on Passover to tell me that
where I need to be spending my time is
the Jehovah's Witnesses website can you
imagine and I thought of calling them
back on stream but that would not be
legal you know it is a we are in a
two-party consent state and that that
simply would not be allowed it would not
be allowed and we can't do that and so
I'm not going to do it okay let me say
thank you to toady Capote who has
subscribed with twitch prime and says
what time is this show getting on the
road anyone no scheduled for a half 35
minutes ago and we're past that now so
it's anyone's guess it's anyone's guess
what time this is going to get on the
road okay if you're just joining me on
youtube remember to smash that subscribe
button and the like button other super
chats coming in let's see here
Jay Harper did you see Trump's anti
Biden ad what are your thoughts I
haven't seen it I haven't seen it if
someone can tell me how to find it I'll
look at it on streem and we can check it
out
NH barracks says are you convinced Biden
will commit to his left promises if so
what convinces you he will follow
through when he has a record of lies and
bad policies okay so here's the deal
with that if you don't if when Joe Biden
says he's gonna do X or Y you think he
won't really do it but you believe other
people will do this stuff they promise I
just think you're deifying someone
you're all politicians make promises
during their campaigns that they don't
end up keeping and you know when people
some people were telling me on Twitter
David you know the the difference
between Biden saying he would expand
Medicare to be for 60-plus instead of 65
plus versus Bernie saying he'll do
Medicare for all is Bernie would have
gotten that done and Joe Biden's not
gonna do this there's no chance Bernie
was gonna get Medicare for all done it's
just a political reality and in the next
if Bernie were president for the next
four years he would not get Medicare for
all done so I think
should be equally skeptical of all
politicians and period that's it I mean
that that's just it and and do I think
Joe Biden's gonna get his campaign
promises done no did I think Bernie was
going to know has Trump know did Barack
Obama know just know and so the point is
what are the options that we have and
what is the best option that's why I'm
voting for Biden am i excited about it
no I'm not excited about it but it is I
would be excited about removing Trump
that would be exciting to me okay Steven
Kenneth destiny bunnell says would you
debate Kyle kolinsky over Biden he said
I I don't I don't take anybody's
assessments of what anybody said I
didn't see it so I'm not gonna respond
to things I have not seen anybody say
Heidi Hirsch Bach says the numbers go
down in this order number of cases
number of hospital admissions number of
deaths yes that's correct
but what what makes what confounds the
data Heidi is the amount of testing can
influence the the official case number
without necessarily telling us what is
actually taking place that's an
important thing to remember time says
the peak of 30k a day isn't a peak of
cases it's a peak of testing 150,000
tests equals 30,000 positives the flat
line is artificial not necessarily no
because even if you keep doing only a
hundred and fifty thousand tests a day
if we are still growing in cases a
higher portion of the hundred and fifty
K would be positive so I know what
you're trying I know what you're arguing
but it's not that way even if you get to
a level of testing and don't increase it
if coronavirus becomes more widespread
more of the hundred and fifty thousand
tests would be positive over time so
it's not quite the way that you are
pointing that out okay let me pull up
the bingo link we will be bingo will be
available today and I will be playing
along I'll pull it up myself first and
then I'll paste it for people generate
card and there it is if you want to play
a trump briefing bingo today I'm pasting
the link in twitch chat and
I am also pasting the link in YouTube
chat and you guys can play along
yesterday Trump came and went so quickly
that I think I only had six or seven
elements of the bingo card yesterday I
really didn't get to that many but you
guy I've I've pasted the bingo link in
the chat in twitch and YouTube so that
whoever wants to play can play marty
marks says what does Marty mark say
better take my BP meds blood pressure
meds before the idiot in chief speaks
Keeton Klepper says Joe exotic has a DIY
haircut tutorial you can use he I should
check that out Randy Wright has
subscribed on YouTube Safari Jay says
aoc says she didn't vote for the bill
she's lying I didn't see that I'm not
sure what you're referring to Tim of the
rosebush says have you read by Karl
Zimring I have I have not read anything
by Carl Zimmern it traces the history of
environmental racism in the United
States through the construction of race
and hygiene I have not seen that
Daniel Krieger says opinions on DNC
replacing Biden with Cuomo I don't know
I can't think of any way that that would
practically speaking happen mavis man
says former Jehovah's Witness here
they're shameless mike miller in' says
nothing Tim of the rosebush says clean
and white by Carl Zimring italics failed
I have not read that book but it does
sound interesting bulkier writer says
debate Kyle kolinsky over not voting for
Biden listen if people don't want to
vote for I already said yesterday I did
a twenty minute video yesterday about
this issue and I'm not gonna keep doing
the same thing and continuing to you
know have debates about it if people
have higher priorities than Trump
getting Trump out of office then that's
fine then they just everybody just needs
to do what they are comfortable with
what is in line with their values and
moral position and that's it you know I
mean for me we've got to remove Trump
Biden's better than Trump on essentially
every issue
I'm trying to think is there any issue
Biden is worse than from bun I'm having
a hard time thinking of one so it's just
like Biden's better so I'm voting for
Biden that'sthat's really it everybody
can do whatever they want there are
people who you know are comfortable with
their vote helping Trump get reelected
so then go do it vote third party right
someone in stay do whatever you want you
know I I can't control everybody I can
only do what I can do and tell people
why I'm doing it that's it
Daniel Rivera says how do we stop do you
find politicians is it media's
responsibility seems like people fall
into the mindset regardless I don't know
the answer but you know for me senators
governors are just people they're flawed
people none of them are perfect none of
them would bring any kind of revolution
to the United States the system is
designed to prevent revolution and it's
it really these are really incremental
questions who is going to push things in
the right direction if you're you know
anticipating a god like candidate
revolutionising the country you know if
you here's something I think is
important to think about and we'll maybe
dig into this next week on the broadcast
show the big advancements in the history
of the United States that have been
planned have come from incremental
change the Progressive Era of the 1910s
and 20s the New Deal era after World War
two the civil rights era of the 1960s
and any time that there has been faster
change it's been because of a cataclysm
and there's I argue I believe it is not
moral to try to cause clad at Cataclysm
and mast mass death in order to have
those larger moments because they do so
much destruction and so much death so as
an example if you go ten years before
the civil war right
very few people would have imagined the
amount of change to the country that the
civil war was going to bring in a
relatively short amount of time but look
at how many people died fighting that
war and so when you look at the really
revolutionary moments in American
history that have brought changed the
change could have been good or not good
they have been cataclysms that involved
untold amounts of death and suffering
when we talk about movements making
change it's been incremental change it's
boring it's milquetoast you know you can
go after the messenger if you want but
again the three really good examples are
the Progressive Era of the nineteen
you know the teens and twenties the New
Deal era and the civil rights era those
were not revolutionary moments where
somebody burnt the system down they were
not acceleration astons and I think we
just have to look at history and that's
what I do so that's why I find it very
fraught to get into a lot of these
debates with people because I just tend
to look at history and that's what
history has taught me okay Dave Matthews
says if we vote for people who don't
represent us and ignore us then they
will always ignore us Constance Neil
says former Jehovah's Witness here they
knocked at my door today crib Li says
love your new look do you have any hats
in your bunker I do yeah on stream a
couple days ago so I have two hats in my
bunker I have just a basic black hat and
and you know we could wear it this way
during stream or you know what's really
funny last time I try to hat under
extreme Stephen Kenneth destiny bunnell
ii came over to my stream just to see
what i was doing as the hat try ons were
happening so this is one possibility i
could do the entire stream like this and
i don't know whether people would enjoy
that and then i have a gray hat and
that's uh oh boy what's going on here
malfunction so I don't know if people
would be interested in me wearing a hat
during the stream but it it feels a
little fraught wearing hats indoors
seems kind of weird so I don't think I'm
gonna do it okay Daniel Rivera says PS
did you see the new anti by Dan ad by
Trump no I have not Robbie twack says
said JFK ich bin ein Berliner said Trump
ich bin ein cheerleader
michael says what do you have to say
about the whole queue thing I know you
probably can't call it by name but the
people that seems to target only seem to
be Democrats I don't I don't really know
anything IQ is some conspiracy right I
mean that's all I really know but it's
just such a waste of time that I don't I
really don't know anything about it
it's just whacked it's wacky wacky
Steven Kenneth destiny Bunnell the first
says you say that progressive
accomplishments can be achieved through
reforms in the USA those are almost a
century ago we need to accelerate
capitalism towards its death vote Trump
to stop the next thoughts I disagree
completely and believe that it is an a
historical argument as I just laid out
Kattan whisper says I love that you're a
progressive and a realist and a realist
I am too I'm more a realist since 2008
and I'm starting to wonder if the two
are mutually exclusive if you are
butthurt or bust you are the problem
Marquess says with Biden I think Kamala
or Warren will be VP I want Warren as we
would at least she would push some
progressive ideas forward what are your
thoughts I would be glad to have
Elizabeth Warren as the vice president
did you see the mass grave in potter's
field New York I did and it is horrible
let me see if I can find that video okay
potter's field it's really bad I mean
it's it's tragic stuff uh okay here we
go
let me pull this up here yeah check this
out I guess there's no audio anyway yes
you know I mean it's like as if we even
need to be dealing with these people but
on another conspiracy theory I I saw was
where are the bodies and it's like well
we have videos here we have videos of
bodies being forklifted into
refrigerated trucks what's wrong with
people you know it's like what you
should see in fact let me do this I'm
gonna try to be respectful here there's
someone I went to high school with who
posts Luna
lunatic stuff about the virus I'll give
you some examples okay so first of all
they're posting Candace Owens
conspiracies about the virus they are
posting Bill Gates conspiracies about
how Bill Gates is involved with the
virus in order to profit from a vaccine
they are posting these really weird
videos of things doctors say but taken
out of context to make it seem like
there's nothing going on
a bunch of their posts have been
actually flagged by YouTube's by
Facebook as fake news like you can't
even see them because they're completely
fake they are quoting Hulk Hogan who
says that we need Jesus not a vaccine to
end the virus they're posting
conspiracies from a guy named David
Dickey who says that the whole point of
coronavirus is that it's a conspiracy
theory to seize people's rights and
destroy the economy deliberately more
doctor foul a conspiracy I mean this is
mental illness it's actually mental
illness and my a friend of a friend of
mine from high school and I got into it
you're on Facebook a couple days ago and
then I realized it's actually mental
illness like I'm not using it as a
pejorative and I went in and I deleted
all of the comments that I had made and
as many of you know I don't often get
involved in Facebook nonsense but I did
and then I realized I'm dealing with a
mentally ill person I went and I deleted
everything and I just you know I'm out
I'm out my friends okay Dave Matthew
says what are your thoughts on a general
strike I think that we are not going to
get one around coronavirus because by
the time people can go back to work
they're going to desperately need to go
back to work
tarah Bennish says you were awesome
David you helped keep me sane through
all of this thanks Terra redrew know
rally drew says this is the only way I
will watch a trump stream I appreciate
that very much
Steven Kenneth destiny Bunnell the first
says evidence for social democracy
working it doesn't this is I'm so bored
it's so lame so this user that posts
messages under Stephen
Kenneth's destiny bunnell used to post
them under Alex Jones and used to post
them under Hugh Jass it's just so boring
I'm so bored by these messages Mikayla
McGonagall says any Friday live stream
with David is a good Friday beautiful I
like that
Zac Bushman says idea mute Pence's daily
tongue bath and take questions not a bad
idea
Joseph van Scoy says I dispute the
incremental change argument the public
option might not be what we want but it
would still be a massive step in the
right direction keep things in
perspective people so listen I am I
posted earlier today to Twitter and if
you're not following me on Twitter
you really should I posted oh by the way
you guys before we even do that I don't
know how many people have seen British
broadcaster sports broadcaster Andrew
Cotter doing coronavirus play-by-play of
his dogs but this this is one of the
best coronavirus things that has come
out of the virus check this out wait a
second is it can people hear that may is
it just me that can't hear it oh I see
my volumes turned down too low this is
the best I love this this will Mabel is
strong chasing the game using that
intensity we saw it in the semi-final
standing at a slightly torn cloth rabbit
for over seven and a half minutes
perhaps a few signs of overconfidence
from our rival a bit of showboating
needs to be careful there's the change
from the classic hold still placed on
the outside though great technique and a
glance at the youngster who shows little
emotion but her mind will be empty 30
seconds to go and her Olive closing in
on victory and that coveted prize of
being told she's a very good dog one
part of control and a switch now Mabel
sensing this might be a chance still
waiting still believing and you wonder
what Oliver's doing here it only has to
hold on going to the upright though high
tariffs with no opposable thumbs high
risk at this stage and it's gone and
Mabel takes it no mercy from the younger
dog who takes this victory
just as time runs out a famous wind
built on patience and sheer belief I
love it anyway okay so that's Andrew
Cotter on Twitter definitely check that
out so here's what I posted earlier Oh
am i something going Oh soon it's start
I'm sorry okay
check out my tweet by the way today what
we are looking for is patreon patrons ok
patreon.com slash david pakman show we
did this yesterday if you've got a
dollar to support our stream we took a
big hit last month because of the virus
and this month we've lost hundreds of
supporters
I don't want your last dollar if you do
have one dollar to support our work
patreon.com slash david pakman show I
will keep it tally and the bar will
start filling up while everybody's
talking so consider patreon.com slash
david pakman show as we get into today's
briefing here today is Good Friday and
the Sunday millions of Christians
celebrate Easter and the resurrection of
Jesus Christ our God at this holy time
we pray that God will heal the sick and
comfort the heartbroken and bless our
heroes as American families look forward
to Easter we're reminded that our story
ends not in despair but in triumph and
renewal very appropriate isn't it
I'd like to provide Americans an update
on our ongoing efforts in the war
against the invisible enemy before I do
that I'll have a couple of notes the
United States in discussions last night
with Mexico Saudi Arabia Russia and in
dealing with OPEC nations we are trying
to get Mexico as the expression goes
over the barrel and Mexico is committing
to do a hundred thousand fewer barrels
president and I spoke last night we have
a great relationship great friendship
yeah
bringing us very much at the border they
have 27 thousand soldiers Mexican
soldiers on our border right now
stopping people from coming into our
country as our wall goes up we're up to
about a hundred and sixty-eight miles of
wall and every day goes up it's speaking
with the president they have a limit the
OPEC nations have agreed to a different
limit reduction of about twenty three
percent so what I thought I would do and
I don't know that it's going to be
accepted we'll find out I'm gonna switch
to c-span because the level is so low
your direct nations have agreed to a
different limit reduction of about
twenty three percent so what I thought I
would do and I don't know that it's
going to be accepted we'll find out the
United States will help Mexico along and
they'll reimburse us some time at a
later date when they're prepared to do
so and we had a great conversation but
we'll find out how that all works out as
you know they're trying to get rid of
the glut of oil there's a tremendous
flood of oil and we don't want anything
to hurt our incredible industry actually
the largest producer in the world now so
we don't want anything to hurt those
jobs those great jobs in Texas and North
Dakota and Oklahoma and everywhere we
have a tremendous energy New Mexico
tremendous energy business and we want
to keep those jobs so we're we're
working on and I think eventually it's
going to work out may work out quicker
than what most people thought possible
and maybe it won't but it'll work out
eventually our experts are monitoring
the data from every part of our country
having to do with the topic that we're
here to discuss in the midst of grief
and pain we're seeing clear signs that
our aggressive strategy is saving
countless lives tremendous progress is
being made although when you look at
some of the numbers I just spoke with
Governor Cuomo with a good talk when you
look at those numbers the numbers of
death people that have died
it's so horrible now on the other side
you have the numbers of beds being used
we're just saying are substantially
reduced that's usually the sign that
it's heading in the downward curve so
New York we know where that is but in
the midst of all this grief in this pain
we're seeing these signs and we're
seeing a very strongly and a lot of that
has to do with the aggressive strategy
in saving so many lives we're saving so
many lives compared to what it could
have been so nobody knows what the
number is but we had a number of a
hundred thousand lives as many as that
is it's impossible to even think of it
and that was the low end with a
tremendous amount of work and a
tremendous amount of you can call it
many different things our people had to
be extremely strong and brave to be able
to put up with what they've put up with
but the thing is saying if I did nothing
two million people would have died as if
doing nothing would have really been a
strategy every other aspect and I I
think I can say 90 percent maybe even
more than that were able to do it
the minimum number was a hundred
thousand lives and I think will be
substantially under that number hard to
believe that if you had 60,000 you can
never be happy but that's a lot fewer
than we were originally told and
thinking so they said between a hundred
and two hundred and twenty thousand
lives on the minimum side and then up to
two point two million lives if we didn't
do anything but it showed a just
tremendous resolve by the people of this
country so we'll see what it ends up
being but it looks like we're headed to
a number substantially below the hundred
thousand that would be the low mark and
I hope that bears out the situation in
Detroit and New Orleans appears to be
stabilizing Detroit has really started
to go up and now it is stabilizing
New Orleans is a great place I have so
many friends there they can't believe
what's happening but it's really
stabilized I spoke with the governor of
Louisiana and as you know we're building
them additional beds right now the Army
Corps of Engineers and FEMA and that is
going to be done and I hope they're not
going to be very well used because I
think they've really I don't think
they're going to need them or certainly
not very many of them we built him a big
hospital of a thousand beds and now
we're we're in the midst of doing
another thousand I don't think they're
gonna be using very many of them that's
a good thing and there was a time two
weeks ago when we said that's not gonna
be nearly enough we're gonna have to
build more but we wanted to wait to see
and I'm glad we waited it just looks
like they're doing really well Louisiana
and the state of Michigan is doing
really much better than we thought in
Washington State we've made enough
progress that the governor is now able
to return an army field hospital so
we're going to take that hospital we
don't think we need any more hospitals
we've built thousands of beds all over
the country and we think we're probably
not going to need that hospital anywhere
if we do we're ready to move it to a
different location in New York we're
seeing hospital admissions declining
very substantially as I said a
nationwide the number of new cases per
day is flattening substantially
suggesting that we are near the peak and
our comprehensive strategy is working
overtime our guidelines to slow the
spread or decreasing the rate of new
cases very substantially and will result
in fewer hospital admissions and we're
seeing that it's incredible I think with
with no exceptions it's looking like
it's lower and again that's because of
the people doing what they had to do
great people and and working with
elected representatives and and the
doctors the nurses and everybody I mean
just everybody everybody so so has been
so amazing right
I was told this morning again please
mention all of those people working in
to the grocery stores and it's true the
checkouts and the clerks and the people
that are really and a number of those
people have become infected so we want
to thank them and a shout out to the
shout out with the tireless devotion of
American doctors and nurses and all of
the medical people we've kept our
fatality rate very very low compared to
other countries my administration is
closely monitoring the data on the
virus's impact on our cherished
african-american communities because
they've been hit hard and the Surgeon
General will be sharing more that
information right after we're finished
here he'll be coming up and saying
exactly what's happening because it's
really and he's truffle certainly worse
than you do it for Trump obvious I'd
also like to provide clarity on the
important point for many Americans on
elective surgeries while we've asked
hospitals to cancel surgeries and
procedures that do not take place at
this time just not to do them now the
choice to delay any treatment still
remains between the patient and their
doctor we're not advising Americans to
postpone medical treatment that their
doctor beliefs should occur now so it's
different kinds of surgery obviously but
we're really getting to the point where
you can start to think about doing that
surgery if necessary pretty soon I think
pretty soon
yesterday I directed Secretary of
Agriculture Sonny to produce sonny
perdue to expedite aid to American
farmers and secretary badou will be
using all of the tools at his disposal
to develop a program and very quickly of
at least 16 billion dollars to provide
relief for farmers ranchers and
producers impacted by the corona virus
right in this time of crisis we must
keep our supply chains moving from the
beginning right from beginning to end
and we're committed to supporting the
amazing men and women who produce supply
I did
last night a statement on social media
and I said I have directed secretary
sonny perdue to expedite help to our
farmers me having trouble he's having
that thing where it looks like he has
loose dentures but he doesn't have
dentures according to his medical record
it's kind of happening today a co-chair
Purdue to use all of the funds and
authorities at his disposal to make sure
that our food supply is stable and safe
and our great farmers are prosperous and
continue to be prosperous we're working
very hard to make sure our food supply
chain is sound and plentiful but we all
know that that begins with our farmers
cattlemen ranchers and producers so
we're going to be working with these
small farmers the big farmers the
cattlemen the ranchers all of the
producers we're going to take care of
them we're working with them right now
we have a lot of money that we found
more much put there through our use of
tariffs and other means and we're gonna
help out our farmers and I don't think I
tell you I've been helping our farmers
for a couple of years because they were
targeted as you know by China no
actually the tariffs that Trump passed
that are the problem for the farmers if
they're very grateful to what for what
we've done on the medical front the FDA
FDA has issued 47 emergency use
authorization x' for advancements and
testing new ventilator designs
innovations and personal protective
equipment and experimental medicines and
dr. Hahn's going to be talking about
that we've cut through the red tape to
give doctors and patients unprecedented
freedom to make their own healthcare
decisions
granting access to potential therapies
and drugs since Monday we've deployed
two major shipments of
hydroxychloroquine from our national
stockpile it's going to various cities
and we are also disposing and getting as
quickly as we can portions of it to the
Department of Veterans Affairs and the
Department of Defense and speaking of
the Department of Defense they're going
to be sending us 10 million n95 masks
that they had and we're in great shape
and every way we're in great shape with
ventilators we're in great shape with
protective clothing we have additional
plane loads coming in but we're not
getting any calls from governor's at
this moment I can speak I think for vice
president pence will be talking in a
little while we're getting we're getting
very few calls from from governor's or
anybody else needing anything they're in
great shape for he's they're serving
dry-mouth I'm seeing him kind of like
lip lick around his teeth as well it's a
good job you've done a great job in that
not really a great job I appreciate it
the whole country appreciates it more
than 2 million coronavirus tests have
now been completed and we're conducting
approximately 100,000 more every day
we're also working to bring blood based
sri ology tests to the market as quickly
as possible so that Americans can
determine whether or not they have
already had the virus and potentially
have immunity
they have immunity of they've had the
virus a lot of them don't even know if
they've had it sometimes it's brutal you
see the Prime Minister seems to be doing
well now I hope he had a rough go of it
and and still is but he's doing better
and then some people don't even know
they had it it could be sniffles it
could be they don't feel perfect but
they've had it there they're the lucky
ones the NIH CDC and FDA are currently
validating these antibody tests to
ensure that they are accurate and
they're doing that at breakneck speed I
think we can say that doctor we're gonna
get them approved very quickly dr.
Hahn's when validated we're confident
that the production will scale up to
tens of millions of tests very quickly
we're leading the world now in testing
by far and I'm going to keep it that way
and we have that other countries are
coming to us and they're wanting to know
about our tests and can they buy the
tests and can they do whatever they have
to do to get the tests and we're going
to make that very soon we'll be in a
position to make that possible because
it's important for them to have it and
we're going to have an announcement on
the word
Health Organization's sometime next week
as you know we give them approximately
five hundred million dollars a year and
we're gonna be talking about that
subject next week we'll have a lot to
say about it we'll hold it every
American should be proud of what our
country is achieved in just a short
period of time the US military is
deployed thousands of personnel to build
23 temporary hospitals with more than
16,000 beds and we have the potential to
build them anymore if we needed them
we're all ready to go but I don't think
we're going to need them which is great
fate news and we built those hospitals
in 12 states and the District of
Columbia using the defense production
act and we used it like a hammer a lot
of the media said oh we weren't using
that we used it like a hammer to a point
where all we had to do is say the words
and everybody gave us Mac's and and
they've done a good job they really have
done a good you know great views just a
moment ago and we've harnessed the full
power of American industry to produce
ventilators and other essential supplies
right now we're making thousands of
ventilators many of which we won't need
but we'll use them in our stockpile and
we'll build that up we'll also help
build up the stockpiles which they
should have had in the States and so
we're working with governor's on that
and we'll also help other countries
there are countries that are calling us
for help they need ventilators and there
are no position to build ventilators we
are we have Ford and General Motors and
many many companies are building
ventilators so we're going to be helping
at a not too distant point we're going
to be helping quite a few of the
countries now we've launched project air
bridge to deliver nearly 300 million
pieces of personal protective equipment
from and around the globe we're also
shipping out 60 sterilization systems to
ten different cities that can each
sterilize up to 80,000 masks each day
and I'm even hearing it can go up to
120,000 mess
certain equipment with certain additions
certain element it's a company in Ohio
that makes it a great company great I
hear it's a great product works very
well I asked that question I said how
come we have to buy so many mess why
can't we sterilize the masks that are
being used and the answer was you can in
this case they say up to 20 times so we
can take a mask certain types of masks
the n95 in particular we can sterilize
them make them very clean up to 20 times
that's a great thing in addition we
passed the largest emergency economic
relief package in American history to
save the US economy and protect the
American worker as you know this past
week which was four active days on the
stock market Good Friday today is not is
not included the markets are closed in
four days we had the biggest market
increased stock market increase that
we've had in 50 years that tells you
that there's a pent up demand that tells
you they want to get back there's
something good going to happen I really
believe that there's something very good
going to happen we have to get back so
think of it in this horrible period this
horrible dark period where this this
monster came and and worked it's
horrible horrible spell over the world
184 countries as of this morning hundred
and eighty four countries we've done
well and I guess the market thinks we've
done well because we had the biggest
stock market increase without one day
we're talking four days instead of five
that we've had in 50 years 50 years
think of that
of course the degrees previously was
also the biggest he won't mention that
people have launched the greatest
mobilization of our society since World
War two deploying every scientific
governmental medical and military
resource to defeat the virus so I want
to just start then with we're gonna
answer questions later we'll have time I
think we have a lot of time today a lot
of people are off as they should be good
Friday but so I'll stick around will
answer questions later I want to start
with deborah birx
a dr. Brooks and you can go over some of
the numbers we just looked at and
that'll be great thank you very much
[Music]
different lining how well we are doing
in a series of metro areas what also has
been encouraging for those of you are
watching
epidemic curves every day and I'm sure
you are and a lot watching them in log
phase because that's how Apogee Mahalo
just like to look at their curves you
can see for the first time that in the
United States were starting to level on
the logarithmic phase like Italy did
about a week ago and so this gives us
great heart that economy in specific
places but we're starting to see that
change obviously a lot of that is driven
by the improvement in New York City
remember for a long time they were over
50% of our cases and 50% of our new
cases that is dramatically changed
because of the impact of what the
citizens of New York and New Jersey and
across Connecticut and now Rhode Island
are doing to really change the course of
this pandemic and really change the
trajectory of new cases we're seeing
that what many states and metro areas
were experienced as twofold and four
fold four fold increases that went to
two fold that now those are going to
eight days between the doubling rate
watching this every day gives us hope
across these metro areas from new york
and new jersey and all through Denver
and of course through New Orleans we
still see cases occurring in the Boston
area and in Chicago but their rate of
increase seems to be stabilizing and we
really want to call out the work of the
mayors of Baltimore and the district and
Philadelphia who have really brought all
of their health health experts together
and working with their communities are
starting to really change the curves in
those areas what we're seeing is where
United and social diseases and that's
been very encouraging to all of us and
it should be encouraging to the health
care providers that are on the front
line many of which are serving
our Americans with such dignity and
respect and ensuring that everybody gets
optimal care and as the president noted
our mortality in the United States is
significantly less than many of the
other countries when you correct them
for our population and that is really
solely the work of our health our
frontline health care providers and so
working with you can really hopefully
you get the theme today that we are
incredibly proud of our public health
leaders at the city level at the state
level at the federal level who are
working together to really change the
course of this pandemic working with
their citizens and their communities to
make these changes and the American
public who has really taken all of this
to heart and stayed home I know last
week we really asked a lot of people in
the Washington and Baltimore area to
consolidate not go out frequently to
grocery stores or pharmacies you can
really see that that's having a huge
impact so it's really about the
encouraging signs that we see but as
encouraging as they are we have not
reached the peak and so every day we
need to continue to do what we did
yesterday and the week before and the
week before that because that's what in
the end is going to take us up across
the peak and down the other side we
continue to really applaud the work of
California and Washington State and
Oregon we're learning from all three of
those states from their public health
officials about how they were able to
keep the virus from ever becoming
logarithmic and I think that's an
important lesson for all of us on how
they did that what the timing was in
case we ever have to face this issue in
the future Thank You mr. president
all right very much mr. president
so again just keeping on the theme that
dr. Burks had had mentioned this is the
end of the week that famous week that we
spoke about last weekend in which we
what actually was predicted to happen
happened was starting to see the
leveling off in the coming down that dr.
Burks had mentioned but it's important
to remember that this is not the time to
feel that since we have made such
important advance in the sense of
success of the mitigation that we need
to be pulling back at all
I was actually hearkened by the fact
that we've been talking about the New
York New Jersey New Orleans and other
areas where they have really big spikes
but there are other parts of the country
in the middle parts of the country where
they're concern to make sure they don't
get those spikes and I really want to
salute the governors of states
throughout the entire United States but
particularly in the central part of the
country because the the governor's after
you see us in these press conferences
and I've had calls over the last several
days from several of the governor's you
know from Nebraska Iowa South Dakota
Utah just about an hour and a half ago I
spoke with the governors of Arkansas and
Wyoming who are really committed to make
sure that they don't get into the
situation where they're gonna have
spikes in their state and they're doing
the kinds of things that they don't get
recognized because people don't talk
about them much but we have a big
country we have 50 states and it's not
only the big cities so if we're gonna
pull out of this we're gonna pull out of
it in the big cities and we're gonna
pull out of it in those areas that
aren't as densely populated and I just
want to give a shout out to them they're
doing an extraordinary job I was really
Pleasant I wouldn't say surprised
because I expected of this country right
but to hear what they're doing and the
commitment that they're putting in to
making sure that we don't have the kinds
of situations that we've experienced
unfortunately in other areas this is
very important I just want to close by
one of the things something I mentioned
yesterday and the day before that there
are a lot of candidate interventions
that are going into clinical trials for
those of you are interested in it I
recommend you go to clinical trials gov
and you'll see
design of a clinical trial and you see
that many of them are the randomized
control trials that are the really gold
standard of how you find out whether
something really is safe and effective
and as the weeks and months and it'll
probably be months sometime in the
summer we'll start to see which are
working which are not and to focus on
those that are we developing and we'll
working I'll be happy to answer
questions later thank you Wow Wow
Thank You mr. president
the White House Task Force has been very
focused on increasing the supply of
personal protective equipment for our
great providers I was one of those
providers a few months ago and I can
tell you nothing is more important than
making sure they have what they need so
in order to increase the supply of n95
masks FDA has worked with industry and
has now authorized two companies who
will supply machines to sterilize n95
masks Admiral pull-up check and FEMA are
purchasing on behalf of US government 60
sterilization machines as mentioned by
the President and they will be
positioned around the country to
increase the amount of supply of n95
masks each machine will be able to
sterilize 80,000 95 masks and 95 mass
per day and we hope to actually increase
that further the vice president and the
White House Task Force challenged us
yesterday
and we responded as a team FDA issued
revised guidance regarding the
laundering of gowns because gowns are
another issue in terms of supply that
we're looking forward on this is not
something that normally happens around
the country but issued this guidance
it's on our website now at FDA so
there's information about how hospitals
can do that to increase the supply we've
heard concerns that maybe hospitals
might not want to do that because of
regulations and I can happy to tell you
that administrative Verma and I have
worked on this certified providers and
suppliers who follow FDI FDA guidance as
posted on the website we'll be compliant
with Medicare and Medicaid requirements
and then finally last week FDA it
provided guidance to manufacturers
on manufacturing specifications for
cloth gowns this is another attempt to
increase the number of gowns typically
it's plastic or other types of materials
and this guidance if followed can be
used by manufacturers to actually make
these gowns and no further regulatory
red tape will be unnecessary they can go
into circulation thank you thanks Chad
[Music]
Thank You mr. president
good afternoon everyone I started off
the week talking about the challenges
that lie ahead and I want to finish the
week just by reiterating what you've
heard
mitigation works it definitively and
quantitatively is working and I want to
say thank you to America for your
efforts to help flatten the curve and to
save lives
but at the president's Direction
yesterday I met with 2,000 Hispanic
leaders from their communities in today
and the vice president led a phone call
that I was on with hundreds of
african-american leaders including the
Reverend Jesse Jackson including Derrick
Johnson of the n-double a-c-p
including the National Medical
Association and the black Nurses
Association to talk about some of the
alarming trends were observing regarding
the impact of kovat 19 on communities of
color and you've heard the stats in New
York City
Hispanics represents the majority of
deaths in Milwaukee County blacks are
25% of the population but almost 50% of
the cases and 75% of the deaths so
what's going on well it's alarming but
it's not surprising that people of color
have a greater burden of chronic health
conditions African Americans and Native
Americans excuse me develop high blood
pressure at much younger ages it's less
likely to be under control and does
greater harm to their organs Porto
Ricans have higher rates of asthma and
black boys are three times as likely to
die of asthma as their white
counterparts as a matter of fact I've
been carrying around an inhaler in my
pocket for 40 years out of fear of
having a fatal asthma attack and I hope
that showing you this inhaler shows
little kids with asthma all across the
country that they can grow up to be
Surgeon General one day
hmm but I more immediately share it so
that everyone knows it doesn't matter if
you look fit if you look the young you
were still at risk for getting and
spreading and dying from coronavirus the
chronic burden of medical ills is likely
to make people of color especially less
resilient to the ravages of kovat 19 and
if possibly in fact likely that the
burden of social ills is also
contributing social distancing and
teleworking we know are critical and
you've heard dr. Brooks and dr. felts
you talk about how they prevent the
spread of corona virus yet only one in
five African Americans and one in six
Hispanics has a job that lets them work
from home people of color are more
likely to live in densely packed areas
and in multi-generational housing which
situations which create higher risk for
spread of a highly contagious disease
like kovat 19 we tell people to wash
their hands but a study showed 30
percent of the homes on Navajo Nation
don't have running water so how are they
going to do that in summary people of
color experienced both more likely
exposure to Cove at 19 and increased
complications from it but let me be
crystal clear we do not think people of
color are biologically or genetically
predisposed to get Kovan 19 there is
nothing inherently wrong with you but
they are socially predisposed to
coronavirus disclosure exposure and to
have a higher incidence of the very
diseases that put you at risk for severe
complications of coronavirus but as the
Vice President shared on the call this
morning this history and I want you to
hear me say this it does not have to be
our nation's future and we're taking
steps now in the midst of the kovat 19
pandemic to reach protect and strengthen
all communities impacted by this disease
and especially our communities of color
more details will be forthcoming but we
are actively working as the vice
president in the CDC director laid out
today data collection targeted outreach
to communities of color and increasing
financial employment education housing
social and health supports so that
everybody has an equal chance to be
healthy and I want to close by saying
that while your state and local health
department's and those of us in public
service are working day and night to
help stop the spread of Kovan 19 and
protect you regardless of your color
your creed or your geography I need you
to know you are not helpless and it's
even more
that in communities of color we adhere
to the taskforce guidelines to slow the
spread yes stay at home if possible if
you must go out maintain six feet of
distance between you and everyone else
and wear a mask if you're going to be
within six feet of others wash your
hands more often than you ever dreamed
possible avoid alcohol tobacco and drugs
and call your friends and family check
in on your mother she wants to hear from
you right now and speaking of mothers we
need you to do this
if not for yourself then for your abuela
do it for your granddaddy do it for your
Big Momma do it for your pop-pop we need
you to understand especially in
communities of color we need you to step
up and help stop the spread so that we
can protect those who are most
vulnerable this epidemic is a tragedy
but it will be all the more tragic if we
fail to recognize and address the
disproportionate impact of kovat 19 and
an array of other diseases and risk
factors on communities of color the task
force in this administration are
determined not to let that happen the
president the vice president have said
we will not let that happen right we
can't fix these issues overnight but I
promise you we will work with your
communities to quickly and meaningfully
move the needle in the right direction
nothing less than the fate of our
families and friends my family and
friends depends on it
Oh nonot pence Thank You mr. president
today the White House coronavirus task
force met and and heard from the
president the gratitude that he and I
and I know all the American people feel
for all the dedicated workers at FEMA
HHS US Public Health Service FDA and all
those that are literally working on your
behalf around the clock to partner with
States to partner with local health
officials and mr. president allow me to
add my my thanks and admiration to all
of the entire team here at the federal
level right on this Good Friday we we
remember those who have lost their lives
to the coronavirus we remember their
families our dedicated health care
workers and our first responders and we
do well on this special day for
Christians across this country to
remember them in our prayers but as you
just heard from dr. Burks and from the
experts it's also a good day to remember
that Good Friday is always followed by
Easter Sunday hmm and there is hope
there's hope in this moment that thanks
to what the American people are doing
every day adhering to the president's
coronavirus guidelines for America
thanks to the fact that Americans are
listening to state and local leaders and
putting the health of their family
members and neighbors first we're
getting there America we're making
progress but it's imperative that we all
continue to implement all of the
guidance in the 30 days to slow the
spread as a certain general just
attested at the president's direction we
engaged more than 400 leaders in the
african-american community today and
allow me to express my appreciation for
their leadership in their efforts in
communicating to African Americans and
other minority populations some of the
unique challenges that those communities
face in the midst of this epidemic and
the CDC as the Surgeon General said is
working on not only studying the issue
but very rapidly
new guidance and we'll be communicating
that new guidance to all of those great
leaders on the subject of testing and
supplies the president gave a great
amount of detail more than 2.1 million
tests have been performed we continue to
work very very closely with FDA and
suppliers around the country to expand
the ability of testing and you just
heard dr. Han reflect on the fact very
soon we will have an antibody test that
Americans will be able to take to
determine whether they ever had the
corona virus I spoke today to the
governor of Colorado jared Polis we've
been in contact with Senator Cory
Gardner about an outbreak at a a
particular meatpacking facility in the
Colorado area great and at this time our
team is working with the governor and
working with the senator to ensure that
we flowe testing resources at this point
there are some 14 people hospitalized
maybe 2 to 300 of the work force have
been impacted and we spoke about
providing those resources this weekend I
want to encourage people in Colorado
that we will we will work to support
that effort but I also want to emphasize
that all the people that are working in
food supply from farmers to meat packers
to distributors to truckers to grocers
continue to have our gratitude as
president Trump has said just a few
moments ago on supplies more than five
billion have been obligated to the
state's 29600 National Guard have been
activated and at the president's
Direction portion of the press briefing
is truly meaningless I mean really you
know the numbers each day of the things
they claimed to have sent or allocated
it doesn't connect to what's actually
been received it doesn't connect the
demand it doesn't connect the
hospitalizations I could its filler and
it is the worst kind of filler I reach
and that's why I'm talking over it it
means nothing as people are pointing out
this is truly truly meaningless finally
let me say as we go in to this very
special weekend into Easter service
okay I know I speak on behalf of of the
president when I say how grateful we are
to all of the churches that have been
there and their ministries have been
working under great difficulty to
continue to provide for the needs of
your members there have been there have
been food drives there have been phone
calls and ministry has continued and we
are grateful for the role on this holy
week that our churches our synagogues
and all of our houses of worship have
played in fact there's been a lot of
spreading of the virus at some of those
churches even if you're not in the pew
this Easter Sunday if you are able it's
still a good idea to give because those
ministries continue donating to the
church even maybe third time we
encourage you to continue to support
them yeah we also want to say very
respectfully to all of the all the
church communities around this country
and all the places of worship to
continue to heed the guideline sight
issue in the president's coronavirus
guidelines for a man we know it's
difficult in this time of year
particularly mr. president to avoid
gatherings of more than 10 but we're
grateful that so many churches
synagogues and places of worship have
done just that and we urge you to
continue to do it and to my Christian
brothers and sisters across the country
let me encourage you with the words we
should all remember that jesus said
wherever two or more are gathered there
he is also right and so you can worship
you can celebrate Easter and know that
you'll be blessed in so doing and you'll
be serving the nation pull them off
Thank You mr. president
Wow great job thank you
okay it's good Friday let's be nice okay
let's be real nice
yeah please good thanks mr. president up
can you clarify a little bit of what the
u.s. offered to Mexico in order to agree
that oil deal and then also go into
detail about what you spoke about hot
oil with personally that's what all of
the OPEC nations met and others and
they're all agreeing to cut back because
there's a tremendous flood we don't even
we're filling up our strategic reserves
we don't even have room to store it in
fact they're using ships to store oil
it's there's never been anything like
this it was being over produced to start
off with and then you had the virus and
that took off 40 percent right there so
we have there's a glut of oil like
nobody's ever seen before that's good in
many ways and depending on where you are
who you are it's bad we have a
tremendous energy business with hundreds
of thousands of jobs we're doing great
number one in the world so they all got
together and they said we're gonna cut
it because we have to get rid of this
tremendous supply now the good news is
gasoline prices I'm seeing 90 cents 85
cents in different parts of the country
a gallon nobody's ever seen that I'm not
seeing that it can anybody tell me is
there dollar a gallon gas right now
anywhere number you don't remember
you're too young but the fact that you
have to go back a long ways to see it so
there's some good the airlines are
trying to get me back having low fuel
costs is good for them and are the
reasons they're not a fraction but a lot
of the steel goes to building what we do
for the oil and engineering firms so you
know that's a that's a double-edged
sword
but it's it's we want to keep our energy
we want to remain independent we will
remain independent I think regardless
but we want to get rid of this
tremendous overflow there's no place to
even store it so the OPEC nations met
they've been meeting and you know I've
hated OPEC over the years absolutely
hated them but obviously it broke down
and we potentially have years worth of
supply a long time before it ever can
catch up even if they do reduce it and
they agreed but Mexico didn't agree it
was one of the few countries that didn't
agree this OPEC plus these are OPEC plus
countries outside you understand
and Mexico didn't agree and I understand
the president very well he has a level
when he came in and he wanted to keep it
at that level oil is important for
Mexico the problem is and I explained it
very strongly you know you're gonna be
selling it for $5 or $10 a barrel so in
the end it's bad but he did have some
political difficulty with it frankly and
I understand that too and it's a small
amount for us it's a large amount for
Mexico but it's a very small amount for
the United States being the biggest
producer so I agreed to pick up some of
the slack so he was going to reduce it
by a hundred thousand barrels reduces
output by a hundred thousand barrels and
I was going to pick up the slack and
they would make it up to us at a later
date they would make up what we're doing
at a later date it could be in a
different form and I don't know whether
or not that's going to be from Mexico
was acceptable I don't know whether or
not that's going to be acceptable to the
other oil-producing nations we'll find
out but it's something that would
certainly be acceptable to me to get it
over the back so Mexico's going to
reduce by a hundred thousand barrels and
that would mean that they're 250 to 300
barrels short we'd make up the
difference they would reimburse us at a
later date okay you mean biggest a
difference by cutting US production by
cutting some US production now the u.s.
production has already been cut because
we're a market driven economy and and
oil is very market driven it sounded
like Trump was saying we would give them
the money for the barrels they're not
producing and at some point they would
give us the money back but when the
reporter said you mean we're gonna make
it up by cutting our production and
Trump said yes but that wasn't what he
was actually saying do you guys think
Trump knows what he agreed to approved
in Alaska that's one of the biggest
finds anywhere in the world so when you
add it all up I think we're probably
number one even in what we have under
we're very lucky we were we grew up in a
land that was rich in a lot of ways but
it's also rich because it has a lot of
oil underneath oil and gas and as you
know natural gas LNG is all over the
country now at a very low price and our
carbon our our atmosphere our
the level of environmental cleanliness
is at its all-time best right live my
best youth lot because we are using a
lot of natural gas in a sense it's true
because of the virus but not because of
anything from some of the newer forms
that people want to see us go to we have
a lot of different forms of energy we're
number one in the world we want to keep
it that way
so we're helping Mexico out we will be
reimbursed in a forum sometime in the
future
this rather than I'll ask you about the
new federal projections in a moment but
first today you tweeted the invisible
enemy will soon be in full retreat given
its invisible without widespread testing
how would you know well I think that
we're going to have it in retreat with
it will it be today no tomorrow no but
it will be at a certain point in the
not-too-distant future it will begun the
widespread testing specifically Mike
well no no because people aren't gonna
go to the hospital people aren't going
to get sick you're gonna know that with
that but we're going to do very
substantial testing we're doing more
testing right now than any other country
in the world but for capita and if you
would like to have that question-answer
i'll have the professional answer it
Deborah
perhaps you could come up we are doing
tremendous testing but you'll know
you're gonna know before anybody because
you're gonna see nobody's getting sick
anymore it will be gone and it won't be
that much longer go ahead ask about the
projections out thank you
Thank You mr. president so the testing I
want to re-emphasize about what kind of
testing we're talking about this is RN a
diagnostic testing that is the platform
that was built to respond to this
epidemic it is the same platform that we
utilize for HIV viral loads and so many
HIV clients have also given up their
space on the machines to have these
tests run for all of Americans this
assay is complicated it's not like an
assay that you have for your other
diseases your strep test or other
diseases like that this is a very
complicated assay that requires I'm a
lot of technical oversight and it's part
of the reason why not all a hundred
percent our machines are running at full
capacity but we had great discussion
with the lab directors about that every
day more are brought online
and so but I think we have to create
expectations of what the daily test
rates will be last year we probably did
three million HIV viral loads or four
million HIV viral loads as a country
we've done over to almost 2.2 million in
four weeks so this is unprecedented and
what we have to do I think that's why
we're working very hard for two pieces
and I want to make sure that people
understand testing is just part of our
strategy the other part of the strategy
has to be this syndromic and influenza
like illness where there's an alert to
an illness and so that we're surveying
where we know the most vulnerable cases
have appeared in the great call that I
had with the mayors and with on the
health officials yesterday and mayor's
today a lot of the rural areas their
primary and as it was in Washington in
California was it the nursing homes so
the the issue is to build a testing
strategy that speaks to our strengths of
laser focusing a strategic approach to
testing when we know what our volumes
are and they increase everyday but we
have to be realistic about what the
volumes will be a week two weeks three
weeks from now and combine that with
strategic surveillance so that we're
testing symptomatic people and their
contacts very quickly to go back to
contact tracing utilizing our complete
strategy and I think we're very much
interested in it's why the president
three weeks ago really put us on getting
an antibody test and I think I called
from the podium for our University
colleagues and Univ and hospitals to
begin analyze abased tests because
that's a blood draw but we really wanted
a finger prick to make it easy and
deployable and that's what's being
worked on now of course we don't want to
promise until we have it because I think
we deserve that the American people
deserve that to have a test that is
efficient to let people know who's been
positive at home unity that's critical
to epidemiologists and public health
officials to know what the penetrance of
a virus was into a community when all
you're seeing are the serious cases and
testing the most symptom
attic and so that's a question that we
still have is this the tip of the
iceberg or is this half the iceberg or
three-quarters of the iceberg what we
have seen to date and we have I just
want to complete the thought by saying
in the areas where we had an outbreak
these large metros Louisiana Denver
Detroit Chicago New York New Jersey but
per capita we've done more tests than
any other place in the world that was
intentional we focused the tests where
with a need was the greatest and the
burden of disease the greatest and now
we're trying to really see how
strategically that very valuable
resource can be utilized around the
countries to create a mosaic of testing
combined with surveillance that's passed
about the new federal projections
there's new reporting today the new
federal projections - just let me ask
you I'd like to ask you if I can about
the new federal projections that suggest
lifting the 30-day shelter-in-place
orders would lead to a spike in
infections have you seen those new
projections from your Department of
Homeland Security and HHS what does mine
when did they say this would take place
what they said that it would take place
if the 30-day shelter-in-place were to
be removed they're three different
examples they haven't seen it I guess
you're saying they were I guess they
leaked it to NBC they didn't leak itas
that's before nobody seen it and they're
the ones are doing destruction to assets
from the HHS and DOJ yeah I'll circle
back we'll find out about it they don't
so what to say something well Peter I
haven't seen that so yeah quote on that
but that's okay I still haven't seen
I've been here all day so what would I
think but that they're talking about is
that whenever you pull back you would
expect that you might start seeing cases
and what we've been talking about what
dr. Burks has just mentioned is that
when you see that that's where you want
your resources to be able to very
efficiently in real time identify
isolate and contact trace so don't let
anyone get any false ideas that when we
decide at a proper time when we're gonna
be relaxing some of the restrictions
there's no doubt you're gonna see cases
I would be so surprised if we did not
see cases the question is how you
respond to them I think that's what they
were referring to right question mr.
president should Americans have to
decide between staying healthy and going
back to work look I think we're going to
do both we're gonna go back to work and
we're gonna stay healthy and staying
healthy is also a proportion if you look
at what we're doing we're looking at a
date we hope we're gonna be able to
fulfill a certain date but we're not
doing anything until we know that this
country is going to be healthy we don't
want to go back and start doing it over
again even though my guess is they're
thinking about May 15 I don't know what
you guys think so just follow up on the
old question the President of Mexico
said that you had agreed that the US
would cut production by 250
barrels per day is that what you agreed
to yes we would which we've already done
by the way but we would agree to a
reduction cut they would agree to do
something to compensate us in the future
don't you make any assurances to Saudi
Arabia that you the United States would
not bail out oil drillers here we didn't
discuss that with Saudi Arabia we just
discussed the numbers we discussed who's
opposed and who's not and pretty much
everybody is in favor of it because
they're getting clobbered they're all
getting clobbered all of those countries
are having problems if you look at Saudi
Arabia that's their source of income
primary source of income by far so they
want to do it Russia wants to do it the
OPEC nations want to do it they all want
to do it so we'll see what happens
there's a difference between wanting to
do it and doing it yeah go ahead oh yeah
fifteen million dollar bounty it has no
seat she's not supposed to be there and
we have news this morning that President
Xi is talking with Nicolas Maduro
expressing his financial support for
Maduro so two questions one have you
discussed this dr. sheet or president xi
you're the US policy on Madeira and our
what is how does it affect a US policy
we will not be happy if that takes place
I am spoken to President Xi of China
about Venezuela about that aspect of
Venezuela but if that took place we will
not be happy okay I will not use
anything I'm concerned about everything
that's why I don't sleep a lot I get
myself concerned about everything
oh my god but I would not be happy about
that go ahead president getting back to
Peter's question a variation of that
question your doctors who are gathered
here seem to be in doubt as to whether
or not the country could reopen on May
the 1st if they come to you before May
the 1st and say the country is not ready
are huge parts of the country are not
ready to reopen on May the 1st right
will you listen to them and listen to
them about everything I think they're
actually surprised I have great respect
for these people all of them and others
instead of working with us I have great
respect for this group in fact I'd
totally foul Qi I said why don't you
move to New York run against AOC you
will win easily so he decided that he's
not going to do that ok I can't by the
way they you know this so some of your
allies have been bashing these doctors
would you tell them to cut it out I can
only say this I have tremendous respect
for these people he's not gonna tell
we've done it very well and when you
look at us compared to others were a big
nation when you look at us compared to
others when you see how we've taken
hesitation from a broken system that I
inherited to having the best tests that
anyone's made anywhere in the world and
other countries are calling us wanting
to use our technology I have great
respect for these people come back I'm
never saying bad about this patient if
they come back users say before May the
1st we can't open on May the 1st
you listen I will certainly listen I
will certainly let's take outside you
remember there is Dino I understand the
other side of the argument very well
because I look at both sides of an
argument I will listen to them very
carefully though please go ahead
thank you mr. president you may have
seen this but JP Morgan came out with a
forecast about GDP growth in the second
quarter was saying a 40 percent decline
in the second quarter of this year well
your Economic Advisers share that view
um I think where my economic advisors
are interested in the third quarter and
really the fourth quarter and I think we
have a chance to do record fourth
quarter numbers because there's a
tremendous pent up demand and you see it
this week I mean what reason would there
be other than faith in us and in this
country faith in this group and me and
here we go our vice president and
everybody governor's perhaps you can add
them into it also what reason would
there be for in a shortened week four
days instead of five spec you have the
biggest stock market game in over 50
years speculation so I think that you
know to me there's a sign hello here's a
sign with all we've been down oh it's a
sign all right I mean we've we've never
been hit I don't know has this country
ever been hit like this probably not
1917 but that was different and it was a
different time and frankly Europe took
the brunt of it we didn't but it was a
terrible time also but probably never
been hit like this right somebody was
saying in fact I was speaking with
Governor Cuomo about it because we were
in New York City a place we love New
York State like the World Trade Center
and that was approximately 3,000 people
well we've doubled that in this same
area we've doubled that more than
doubling substantially more and it's
obviously going you know we had our
highest number yesterday and the day
before okay with all of this news what
would lead you to believe that we're
gonna have the best stock market week
shortened wig back in 50 years almost
broke the all-time record you know that
is that's a pent-up two men now that's
my opinion we the other thing is we're
doing tremendous stimulus plans and
despite what you reading you know this
back and forth but we are getting along
with the Democrats they want to see
something happen
we have to help our workers we have to
help our small businesses we have to
help we have to help our restaurants I
think deductibility will be great for
entertainment restaurants all of that
look I think with the stimulus with the
people with what we've got going with
all of the things we're going to be
meeting with the airlines over the
weekend we have a great plan for the
airline so we've got to keep the
airlines going you know it's never been
a great business but it's a very vital
business for the country we're gonna be
meeting with Boeing we're gonna be
meeting with a lot of companies that are
great companies and were great companies
a short while ago I mean we can't let
anything happen to Boeing right it's you
know that so much potential you talk
about potential can anything have more
potential than that so we have a lot of
very exciting things taking place we
have tremendous plans we have tremendous
stimulus and I think we have a chance to
do really well so this quarter isn't the
quarter I'm looking at the third quarter
we start to think about it and I think
fourth quarter is going to be at a level
that Gabi we haven't seen before I think
our country with the stimulus with all
that we've been through we've learned a
lot don't forget we've learned about
pandemics and epidemics we've learned a
tremendous amount and with all that
we've learned as an example we're making
ventilators we have thousands of them
being delivered in the very near future
we have countries calling us can we have
ventilators that would have been an
unthinkable call I'd be I wouldn't know
what to say they have people dying but
maybe one first was to say we have
plenty before the surge in New York they
need far fewer hospital rooms or far
fewer hospital beds in particular than
we thought and I have to say dr. Burks
told me that four weeks ago six weeks
ago remember you said that number is too
high we don't need that money and based
on what she said and others we did what
we had to do we actually gave the
maximum we built Javits we sent the ship
in we then made the ship kovat because
maybe there weren't a lot of people on
the roads you didn't have the accidents
that we thought other
unrelated X and there's nobody driving
you know normally have a lot of car
accident you have a lot of motorcycle
accidents you have people going to the
does anyone remember what the question
was I actually forgot so a lot of things
have happened I think we have a chance
to be stronger than before I really do
I think this dvdp down 40% we're doing I
think it's very very important please go
ahead president asked about credit and
debt as well know even many American
individuals families have had to tap
their credit cards during this period of
time and businesses have had to draw
down their credit lines are you
concerned mr. president that that may
hobble the US economy all of that debt
number one and number two would you
suggest to credit card companies to
reduce their fees during this time
what's something that we've already
suggested we're talking to them business
interruption insurance I'd like to see
these insurance companies you know you
have people that have paid when I was in
private I had business interruption when
my business was interrupted which was
author who a hurricane or whatever it
may be I have the business where I had
it I didn't always have it sometimes I
had it sometimes I have a lot of
different companies but if I had it I'd
expect to be paid you have people I
speak mostly to the restaurant tourists
where they have a restaurant they've
been paying for 25 30 35 years business
interruption they've never needed it all
of a sudden they need it and I'm for a
very good at reading language I did very
well in these subjects the amount of a
good at language and really won't see
the word pandemic mentioned now some
cases it is it's an exclusion we did
coda but in a lot of cases I don't see
it I don't see reference and they don't
want to pay up I would like to see the
insurance companies pay if they need to
pay if it's fair and they know what's
fair and I know what's fair I can tell
you very quickly yeah but business
interruption insurance that's getting a
lot of money to a lot of people and
they've been paying for years you know
sometimes they just started paying but
you have people that have never asked
for business interruption insurance and
they've been paying a lot of money for a
lot of years for the privilege of having
it and then when they finally need it
the insurance company says we're not
going to give it why can't let that
happen
please go ahead
on March 6 he said anyone who wants
tests can get a test now you're saying
that there that you would be open to
reopening the government without having
a National Testing system how do you
square those two statements given that
there are still issues with testing
going for it and how you tell there's
not a lot and it's a good question
there's not a lot of issues with testing
certain sections of the if we go to Iowa
we go to Nebraska we go an interest in
the Idaho is very interesting because
they had a few breakouts small breakouts
but they're very very capable states and
they're big distances a lot of land a
lot of opening you don't need testing
there you know where you have a state
with a small number of cases some states
with almost none West Virginia hung in
for a long time as you know with none
for a long time so when you have that
you don't need testing you don't have to
test every person in the state of Iowa
as an example you don't have to test
every single person to say let's open up
and let's get the tractors moving and
let's get the corn and let's open up all
of the different things they do in that
great state you don't need that with
that being said if there's a little hot
corner someplace we'll be testing but I
think that speaks to this very well the
same thing in New York that's what we
talked to Governor Cuomo about this
morning we have the Abbott test which is
very quick and very easy it goes very
fast then we have a lesser test that we
talked about where we can talk about a
larger area but you're going to know so
we're going to do testing but you don't
need to test 320 from same places with
no people and no tests have no cases
that's interesting one it's unnecessary
vast numbers vast areas of our country
don't need this I think you agree with
me on that you just don't need it now we
have certain hot spots so Louisiana's a
hot spot New York's a hot spot Detroit's
a hot spot and then you have certain
areas in certain hot spots that you have
to even go more so and we're doing all
of that
remember this we've done more testing
than any country in the world
we have the best test and we developed
the silver a very short period again
please the african-american experience
the question for you and a question for
the Surgeon General option
free for you mr. president we know that
these health disparities have existed
for a long time among african-americans
Latinos and other people of color why
did the administration possibly have a
plan directed those communities to
prevent high death rates knowing that
the health disparities were there well
we do have a plan and one of the things
I'm most proud about is what I've been
able to do for the african-american
community right here we have the lowest
job numbers in the history the low of
our cut this was just before the virus
came well I'm just saying because you
know this has been here for three weeks
right so just before token American
community had the lowest unemployment
the best employment numbers more African
American people and communities have
been thriving if you look at our
opportunity zones and what we did Tim
Scott who is fantastic a fantastic
senator and temptingly opportunities
owns more jobs for African Americans
than ever before better health care that
they've ever had before all of these
things the Surgeon General spoke to it
and he spoke to it I thought really
brilliantly I found it very interesting
what he said oh yeah I'd love you to
come up and answer the second part of a
question because I think you're you
would do it a much better job than I
would that's true thank you quick
question for you you you said that
african-americans and Latino should
avoid alcohol drugs and tobacco Yul said
do it free or voilá
do it for Big Mama and pop pop there are
some people who are going to there are
some people online they're already
offended by that language and the idea
that you're saying behaviors might be
leading to these high death rates could
you talk about whether or not people
could you I guess have a response or
people who might be offended by the
language that used well I use that
language because that's the language I
had been meeting with the n-double-a-cp
with the National Medical Association
with others actually talked with with
Derek Johnson multiple times this week
the head of the n-double a-c-p and we
need targeted outreach to the
african-american community and I use the
language that is used in my family I
have a Puerto Rican brother-in-law
I call my granddaddy granddaddy I have
relatives who call their there their
grandparents Big Momma so that was not
meant to be offensive that's the
language that we use and that I use and
really I continually target our outreach
other to those communities it is
critically important that they
understand it's not just about them rude
and I was very clear about that it's not
just about what you do but you also are
not helpless we need to do our part at
the federal level we need people to do
their parts at the state level and we
need everyone black brown white whatever
color you are to follow the president's
guidelines there coronavirus guidelines
and do their part because when I talk to
the n-double-a-cp
and three weeks ago it's important to
note that one of the things they asked
me was can you help dispel the myths in
this community that that people actually
can't get coronavirus if they're blind
right that would emit that without there
that's actually very important for us to
squash here yeah and all Americans avoid
tobacco alcohol and drug use
absolutely it's especially important for
people who were at risk and with
comorbidities but yes all Americans so
thank you and I will clarify that all
Americans need to avoid these substances
at all times I put out a smoking
cessation report in January I put out a
advisory against youth and pregnant
women using marijuana last year and that
was not directed towards any one race
now only black and Latino people should
stop drinking if healthy as possible at
this critical time you did it
beautifully I can't do it any better
than that
and I know Jerome personally and I can
just testify that he made no not even a
hint of being offensive at all with that
I thought that was appropriate thanks
Bob he was not a Kentucky Jerome's done
a fantastic job our Surgeon General I
just hope nobody steals him and he goes
to one of these big companies for a
fortune don't leave us
right don't leave us to release
he's doing a great you are happy and
you're doing a great job and everybody
everybody tells me that too so I
appreciate it thank you uh please thank
you so Google and Apple will have
announced that they are jointly enabling
contact tracing on their mobile phone
operating systems and I was wondering if
this is something you would consider or
maybe the top yeah that's a no freedums
problems and a lot of other things isn't
something we're gonna look at it
certainly and we know they've done that
and it's highly it's very new new
technology it's very interesting but a
lot of people worry about it in terms of
a person's freedom we're gonna take a
look at that a very strong look at it
we'll let you know pretty soon Brandon
oh yes please
so can you explain why it is appropriate
in the middle of a pandemic should be
talking about cutting or eliminating
funding for the World Health
Organization well we're gonna talk about
the w-h-o next week in great detail I
didn't want to do it today
Good Friday I didn't want to do it
before Easter they also getting right
before we have all the facts but over
the years many years we've been paying
them from three hundred to five hundred
and even more million dollars a year
China has been paying them less than 40
over the years so we're paying them more
than 10 times more than J the PR
companies are still figuring out how to
best scapegoat the WH o and he's gonna
need until Tuesday to figure that out
China always seems the bet to get the
better of the the argument and I don't
like that I really don't like that I
don't think that's appropriate I don't
think it's fair to the American people
and you know I'd tell that to President
Xi I'd tell that to dr. Ted Rose I spoke
to him one time I I think he's a very
nice man I liked him but we're gonna be
talking about that next week in great
detail we're looking at it very very
closely we want to make sure money is
properly spent but again why is the
United States paying 500 million dollars
a year that's a lot and why is okay
that's a lot and why is China paying
last year this year forty-two million
dollars but generally under 40 so it's
in the 30s so we're at 500 450 to 400
401 different amounts different years
and they're at 40 38 36 35 32 31 no no
but but you have to ask yourself that
question and then the answer always
turns out to be in China's favor well I
have the same thing with the world trade
is dead interesting world trade so we
have world health and we have world
trade so we have the World Trade
Organization and until I came along we
were losing cases so many cases it was
ridiculous we were always losing these
cases in almost every case and now we're
winning cases we just won seven billion
dollars because they know I'm not gonna
put up with it China has been
unbelievably taken advantage of us and
other countries you know further since
they're considered a developing nation I
said well then make us a developing
nation too they get big advantages
because they're developing nation India
a developing nation the United States is
the big developed nation well we have
plenty of development to do Oh Mike okay
and now we're winning cases because they
know that if we're not treated fairly
I'm gonna pull out now you never heard
this before because nobody ever talked
about the World Trade Organization but
the World Trade Organization has treated
us very unfairly but they know I'm not
going to put up with it because all of
these countries are taking advantage of
the United States now in the courts and
the court system we're not approving new
judges over the last year we're not
going to approve them and Bob lighthouse
is working very hard on that but we had
always a minority position meaning
numbers of judges so we'd have a
minority number of judges I said how do
you win with a minority number of judges
but all of a sudden we're winning and
the reason we're winning is they know we
can stack the judges we have no chance
of actually winning anything but it's
just this very recently and the money is
pouring in
and we want other cases too we want a
lot of cases but you know from covering
it I know you know that the United
States was taken advantage of by the
World Trade Organization and by the way
speaking of China if you look at the
history of China it was only since they
went into the World Trade Organization
that they became a rocket ship with
their economy they were flatlined for
years and years frankly for many many
decades it was only when they came into
the World Trade Organization that they
became a rocket ship because they took
advantage of all there was I'm not even
blaming him I'm saying how stupid were
the people that stood here and allowed
it to happen but we don't allow that is
that the only but now we're starting to
win cases how about somebody new for a
change come on polls and school
districts are closing across the country
Florida governor Rhonda Sanchez has not
ruled out closing for opening out
schools in May saying that many kids are
not vulnerable to this disease do you
agree with that assessment
and you believe that schools would
recommend that schools open up and to
those states that have it well I have a
lot of confidence in Rhonda Santos a lot
of faith in Rhonda Sanchez during a live
decision he's doing a great job as
governor Ron de santis I had read where
he's thinking about opening up the
schools earlier than the date at the end
of the month I'd have to look at the
numbers but again you know I like to
allow governor's to make decisions
without overruling them or because from
a constitutional standpoint that's the
way it should be done suggest if I
disagreed I would overrule a governor
and I have that right to do it but I'd
rather have them you can call it
Federalists you can call it the
Constitution but I call it the
Constitution I would rather have them to
make their decisions but he's made a lot
of good decisions and he hasn't said
he's going to but he's thinking about it
so I'll take a look at
so one of the doctors that if you allow
children back in the schools
you know wouldn't that pose a threat to
spreading the virus even further to some
of those vulnerable I think the answer
is obvious but if you want either would
you want to just talk about that maybe
yeah I mean from from from fewer public
health issues is that if you have a
situation in which you don't have a real
good control over an outbreak and you
allow children to gather together they
likely will get infected and if they get
infected the likelihood that they will
bring the infection home so that's
really is a risk I don't know the
situation at all in any detail and then
not specifically speaking about Florida
I'm just speaking generically about what
happens when you have infections in the
community and you have a congregation of
people such as in classrooms that that's
a risk under 25 doctors in the country
yes yes the governor the guy said that
no one under 25 has died it I guess you
could clarify the people under 25 can
die as a result of this yeah I'm not
sure
again I in the country okay let's do
that
because I don't want to have to be
answering for a particular state yes
people under 25 have died virus disease
in the United States of America yep if
you reopen the country in May and
there's a new outbreak were a spike in
infections are you open to the idea of
shutting the country down again
depending on the outbreak yeah and
that's happened as you know with a
couple of countries you know what I'm
doing I'm watching other countries in
many cases they're ahead of us from the
standpoint that it attacked them before
us it hit them first and I'm watching
what's happening with respect to certain
other countries some of them obvious
some of them less obvious and what
they're doing and the success that
they're having and that's going to play
a large part of the role I'm also we're
also setting up a Council of very very
great doctors and businesspeople we're
going to be a noun
seeing it on Tuesday of some great
people the task force is the second
beyond this is beyond economic this is
really I call it the opening our country
task force or opening or I think it'll
get it done that confused with Mike's
task force which has done so great
and we're gonna have the great business
leaders great doctors we're gonna have a
great group of people
we'll probably do it by teleconference
because we don't really want them
traveling in for their own purposes I
don't think it would look good also but
we don't want them traveling in so we'll
do teleconference we did one the other
day with the banks and it was very
successful to teleconference itself and
we'll be announcing names on Tuesday
who's on that and that'll play a role
but ultimately you have to make that
decision
and then I'll have to make a decision do
we close a little area that's a hot spot
I do say this Jim I want to get it open
as soon as possible
this country was meant to be open and
vibrant and great not where people are
you know staying and you know I'm not I
am I would love to open it I'm not
determined anything the facts are going
to determine what I do but we do want to
get the country open so important so I
have a task force I'll have a council
it's going to be announced on Tuesday
with names that you have a lot of
respect for a lot of great names
different businesses different people
bipartisan I I didn't even ask I mean
honestly I think it's bipartisan the one
thing I didn't ask a you Republican or a
Democrat hard to believe but I didn't
ask so it would be and I want their
views on what they think also very
important different parts of the country
because you go to the Midwest it's
different than perhaps the east coast or
the west coast or the west coast those
numbers are really pretty amazing on the
west coast very interesting so we're
going to be announcing that in a very
short well probably Tuesday
this present government officials in
Latin American and Caribbean nations
Bahamas Cayman Islands have been saying
that US authorities are blocking the
shipment of PPE in certain cases and I'm
wondering if you could speak to that as
well as knowing we have a tremendous
force out there naval force and we're
blocking the shipment of drugs so maybe
what they're doing is stopping ships
that they want to look we're not
blocking what we're doing is we're
making sure we don't want drugs in our
country and especially with the over 160
miles of wall it's getting very hard to
get through the border they used to
drive right through the border like they
owned it or a certain way they did they
could drive right they had human
trafficking they had all of a sudden
they have a powerful wall up and they're
not driving through that wall that wall
is tough and it's also loaded up with
equipment cameras and sensors and
everything you can think of on top of
that we have drones flying back and
forth over it so so it's in very very
powerful it's a very powerful barrier
between Mexico and the United States a
lot of people though what they're doing
now is they're trying to come in through
the waterways whether it's the Gulf or
the ocean itself and what we're doing is
we're being very tough and we're being
tough because of drugs and also human
trafficking and remember the image Rafic
is mostly females it's mostly females
it's horrible and what we're seeing is
horrible but you have a big we have a
human trafficking human trafficking
problem worldwide the likes of which you
know you think of it as an ancient thing
it's not ancient it's bigger now than
it's ever been before the last ten years
because every Trump the internet the
internet made human trafficking to the
extent that it is now which is massive
the internet the internet made it so we
are we have a big naval force that's
stopping so maybe when you mention that
maybe their ships are getting caught but
we are we are stopping a lot of ships
and we're finding a lot of drugs
yeah please thank you sir on the
additional money for small thank you but
that's okay go ahead
on the additional might for small
business I apparently speak Treasury
secretary munitions speaking with with
the Democrats in Congress yeah are you
allowing you to talking about the new oh
yeah the new 250 billion dollars 250 are
you willing to give in to the Democratic
demands for additional money for
Hospital states and cities in that
interim round I'd rather have that be in
phase four I don't deny it I I think
it's fun but I think it should be in
phase four and I think we should have
infrastructure and I think we should
have a payroll tax moratorium because
that's something that over a period of
time the workers get you know sort of
semi immediately it's over that period
of time it starts immediately but it's
over a period of time if your work I
mean there are a lot of people I'm one
of them that would have liked to have
seen the payroll tax cut as a permanent
cut but we should do the double edged
meaning business employee payroll tax
cut so we're talking about that and I'm
certainly okay with helping the states
and helping the hospitals I just think
because look the hospital's need help
you see what they've gone through and
the states need help some states in
particular need help they need big help
I'm willing to look at that very
strongly but I like looking at it and
phase for the 251 is actually the plan
is working out well the banks are
getting started with the distribution
they've taken thousands and thousands of
applications the numbers aren't even
believable the number of applications
right we just along put Bank of America
and Wells Fargo and I guess City
Citibank is just now kicking in and also
what nobody's talking about the
commercial banks the the community banks
everyone's talking commercial banks the
community banks are doing tremendous
volumes and they're probably doing them
faster from what I understand I hear the
community banks frankly are the easiest
ones in terms of getting the money out
so the money is getting out the
applications are far beyond what we ever
anticipated and that's why we're good
that's why we're going cuz this is money
that goes essentially to the workers who
we want the businesses to hold on to
their workers because once they lose the
workers they're never opening again it's
not going to happen okay in the back yes
sir
Gordon wolf from Wall Street Journal I
wonder if you could expand a little bit
on here like the form that Mexico would
take the reimbursements like what form
would that take you simply add it to the
tab for the wall and you mentioned and a
second question by man well there's no
real cost because we're going to produce
a little bit less so number one it's
staying in the ground you have it you
have it for another day it's actually
cheaper than storing it where you take
it out and you deliver it to a massive
well like the strategic reserves our
national strategic reserves where has to
be brought there and that's you know an
expensive process in itself just some
people and the reason there's so many
questions about oil is everything Trump
says doesn't really make sense and the
reporters recognize it but you're gonna
see that you never thought having
covered I know you cover it you never
thought you'd be seeing oil at $20 a
barrel but how about $10 a barrel that
you'd never thought you'd see so we are
looking at it very strongly there is no
real cost
I was helping Mex I want to help Mexico
out we have a great relationship with
Mexico great relationship with the
president I really like him a lot he's
been terrific to us in the border
because he stopped he stopped you don't
see the caravans coming up anymore you
don't see all the problems when I took
office it was unbelievable what was
going on and they are really they have
been helping us a lot and we've been
helping them a lot you know they make
product for us they sell it to us and
it's fine it's a good relationship it's
in sometimes it's a great relationship
so he could not have done any more than
that and I think there was political
reasons for that for him that other
other nations don't have they don't have
that you know the nations that we're
talking about the 22 other nations that
we're talking about they just don't have
that problem
so it doesn't cost us anything and yet
it's very valuable we will be reimbursed
in the future maybe in the near future
maybe in the more distant future but
we'll be reimbursed by Mexico in a
certain way and it'll be fine but we get
Mexico over the hump now with all of
that being said that doesn't mean the
deal is going to happen anyway because
they still have a lot of different
states but this was one of the stumbling
blocks okay go ahead
China and some other countries have been
particularly active seen as maybe taking
advantage of the US during this process
during this period tried particularly
active in the South China Sea got a
carrier down obviously what's your
message to some of these adversaries in
matters well look the way I view it is
this China has taken advantage of the
United States for 30 years okay I
mentioned the World Trade Organization
China has taken advantage of us through
that and using rules that are unfair to
the United States and they should have
never been allowed to should have never
been allowed to happen when China joined
and was allowed to join under those
circumstances the World Trade
Organization that was a very bad day for
the United States because they had rules
and regulations that were far different
and far easier than our rules and
regulations plus they took advantage of
them down to the last and you know stun
and you study China and you know what I
mean they took advantage of them like
very few people would even think to take
advantage of them and again they are
considered right a developing nation we
are not considered a developing nation
they given advantages okay for many
years China has ripped off the United
States and then I came along and right
now as you know China's paying 25% and
we've taken in billions and billions and
billions of dollars in tariffs from
China and I know a lot of the people
kept saying oh no we're paying well
we're not paying you know countries are
different
not every countries China but China
would devalue their currency and they'd
also pour out money and they essentially
were paying most of those tariffs not us
and as you know we've taken in tens of
billions of dollars they targeted our
farmers but we took in so much money
that I was able to give back one year
was 12 billion one year was 16 billion I
was able to give back our farmers the
money that they were targeted hurt China
bought 12 billion and bought 16 billion
one year 12 one year 16 I was able to
give him back to 12 and then give him
back to 16 the farmers and they weren't
talking
in business now we're doing it because
they got targeted in a different way now
I'm going to be very interested to see
so we signed a deal with China and under
that deal they're supposed to buy
substantially in excess of 200 billion
dollars from us that's not only farm
product it's manufacturing product it's
lots of different things they're gonna
buy a lot I just want to see if they
live up to that deal I know President Xi
I would say he would live up to the deal
but remember this
I never took off the tariffs it's still
25% that's how big 25% to an era 50
billion dollars so for the first time
and you saw her also now again I'm going
before the virus it cuz that's sort of
like that's like let's start all over
again okay I can't tell you that yet
because that chapter hasn't been written
yet he's falling apart somebody's got Oh
a few weeks ago the deficit with the
United States and China was coming way
down nobody's seen that nobody has ever
seen that before but the deficit has
come way down so now we start a new
chapter and I can only tell you if a
smart person is standing where I'm
standing we're gonna do very well with
China right and I think it's I have to
also say this I think our relationship
and having the relationship I have with
China is a good thing but for the first
time we're benefiting instead of being
the sucker right I could you know they
got taken advantage for years nobody you
know I said to China how did this ever
happen I got to know him very well
the reporters regretting even asking
this right I mean this is just this is
crazy ranting I'm talking about
I say how did this ever happen they
looked at me and they said but nobody
ever called us we didn't have a deal
it's not like we had a bad deal we had
worse we didn't have any deal at all so
they just took advantage think of it 500
billion dollar-a-year deficit not 500
millions a lot of money right it's not
everyone thinks I've made a mistake when
I say 500 trillion no what do you mean
500 million I said 500 billion
Billy said with China for a long time
but it was 200 it was 300 was 400 was
500 556 billion 507 500 billion dollars
plus but your deficit with China now I'm
charging them terrorists and you know
it's very interesting a lot of people
that don't want to do that they all
agreed because China has taken advantage
of this country like nobody has ever
taken we have built China with the money
we gave them now this may be the worst
answer he's ever given and I mean it
reminds me of that whole John Trump
nuclear weapons thing but just 10 times
as long so I'd like to ask you a
question and then ask a question from
one of the reporters who couldn't be
here because of social coding thank you
thank you I was wondering - you have
been tested for antibodies if you've
taken antibiotics or yes and none that I
know if I've had some tests
Noel told me no no it should be all done
task force been tested for antibodies
that'll come out they've just developed
those sort of new okay so this question
is from Andrew find work with Newsweek a
significant amount of federal aid was
made available to Boeing and recently
signed carries actually package but
according to sources Boeing executives
are still planning around the playoffs
so should Boeing or any company and
accepts federal aid to stay in business
during these pandemic and penalized to
laying off workers after doing so yeah
well the eight has have been given yet
but they will be asking in my opinion
they haven't even asked yet Boeing is
not S parade yet but I think they
probably will now at the same time they
do have to run a company you know this
isn't a great time to sell aeroplane so
let's not kid ourselves okay if you're a
business person Boeing makes airplanes
they had a big problem with one but they
make the greatest airplanes they make
the best airplanes in the world they had
the problem with one they got it too
complex it becomes so complex you have
to be number one in your class at MIT to
be able to fly it it's a mistake every
two years they want to make it more and
more I mean they had great success with
the 737 the Boeing 737 then all of a
sudden they do the max and they say
let's make it more complicated let's put
on different engines let's do this let's
do that it was not exactly a good
decision bad decision
very bad horrible decision number one
human lives and number two Horrible's
what's happened to the company here's a
company from a business standpoint it
was like probably the greatest company
in the world in my opinion I think it
amounts to 1% of GDP some people say
it's a half I think it's one but here's
one of the greatest companies anywhere
there were maybe the greatest and boom
now on top of what happened there with
the two planes and they say they have
that fix that's good they say it have it
fixed undisputably in fact somebody said
they gave me something I said you should
say it that way they said sir this is
now a safest airplane in the air I said
that's what you should say that's a very
good statement it's the safest airplane
in the air that's a very good statement
you
use it I said by the way you're changing
the name but whether you do or not you
should use that but he said that a
bowing person said to me it's the safest
airplane in the air that's a great thing
but we know they're gonna need help now
does that mean they're gonna need help
and they should keep people that they
absolutely don't need that business is a
very cyclical business like many
businesses frankly so that determination
hasn't made they have not spoken to us
yet I think they will be maybe they
won't need help that'll be great look
Boeing made so much money who would have
there who would have thought they could
have made all of those planes that are
parked all over the place in many cases
I guess payments not made but who would
have thought they could do that and
they're still solvent the company okay I
mean what a tragic thing happened in
numerous ways but also economically so
when they see us making sure that Boeing
is strong again is very very powerful
and very important and we'll do whatever
is necessary to do please should we keep
this going everybody keep it going for a
while yes we have time if you want
surely you're not gonna criticize me
that the conference was too long you
know if I leave short yesterday left
sure it was too short if I stayed too
long they said was too long I think it's
something we're gonna get it just right
okay should we continue should we
continue to speak have you had a chance
to speak to Boris Johnson Susie can I
have not no I I have a call just to wish
him well to his to his group no I don't
want to be calling him now I want him to
get better he's a great guy he's become
a friend of my real friend of mine yeah
you know he has a great feeling for our
country for obviously for his country he
loves it he's he's a tremendous guy so
more complicated he's become I think
he's probably right now he was very high
Joe sir I think you might be a hundred
percent popularity right now I think
he's
you know where they talk about approval
polls right you ever hear that term I'm
sure you never heard that I hear it all
the time
his approval rating must be about 300%
but he's a he's a great guy he was a
great guy before and I think people see
what he's been through what he's been
through and they say a big turn so let's
see what happens let's hope and if I may
where do you see the use of something
like immunity certificates or documents
or passports when we get time to
something like issues immunity
certificates once we get transferred
body testing whether this would be
useful way well I see a lot of yeah I
see a lot of different things we're
gonna be very careful for who comes into
the country look my opposition party
wants to have open borders like this is
a case where I'm very glad that my
position is I don't want open borders I
want very strong borders that includes
not only on the southern border our
southern border with Mexico and you
could also say our northern border with
Canada but we want to have strong
borders and I think this is maybe one of
the learning points we learned something
about borders we need borders the
country needs borders to be a great
country and this is I think this is a
great point go ahead you have something
else I wasn't just thinking about for
borders I just thought for ordinary
Americans who are currently stuck at
home if they're tested friends bodies
they did it turns out they've had the
disease and therefore shouldn't be
infected again some sort of
documentation that would allow them to
go back to work safely you mean once
they get better okay so they have the
disease and they're better and they have
the immunity now they they have
supposedly according to what I'm hearing
it could be for a long period could be
for a lifetime it could also be for a
year or two I'm hearing Tony so nobody
has told me yet if it's for a year if
it's for two years or a lifetime like
chickenpox they say if you have
chickenpox you have immunity
they say for a lifetime I hope that's
true but but nobody's actually told me
with certainty maybe because they don't
know yet you don't know yet because it's
new you know this came upon us nobody
knew we just we just they do know you
have it for a period of time and it's
strong for a period of time they don't
know that
hence the antibodies that were making so
somebody was really makes antibodies
we're making it and he got better a
young person relatively young person 35
and physically fit you know and he he
got better he made it barely but he made
it his first thing that he did when he
was better I want to give I want to give
whatever I can give to help other people
because nobody should go so we don't
know yet
how long if you'd like to add anything
to them but we don't know yet if it is
it a year it will be a year but is it
more than a year and only time is going
to tell okay thank you will you have
governor's mayors members of Congress on
the open the country council that you
talked about yeah I think so
I think we're gonna put some governor's
I've gained great respect for governors
both Republican and Democrat I've
actually become friends with some of the
Democrat governors that I wouldn't have
really had the privilege of getting to
know and governor Murphy of New Jersey's
very liberal guy I'm not but we've had a
great relationship John Bell as you know
I call him John Bell but John bel
Edwards people call him John Bell sort
of a cool name who calls it from
Louisiana I think I have a very good
relationship with him a Gavin Newsom
honestly I think we find everything
we're fighting right now I want
automobiles to be made cheaper and safer
and stronger and but you save three four
thousand dollars per autumn and
environmentally equal or better maybe
and we're fighting on that we're
fighting a lot of different things we
fight on the border he wants open
borders I want why I want people to come
into our country illegally illegally
I've gotten very friendly with Gavin
Newsom he's done a very good job here I
think I've gotten very friendly I mean
he's been I think sort of a friend of
mine for a long time don't get to see
him much but Governor Cuomo of New York
would talk all the time I told you I
spoke from literally the last call just
before walking in here well I've gotten
to I've really developed a lot of
good friendships with the governors and
including the governor's I think Mike
DeWine Republican but I think he's done
a great job in Ohio so yeah I want to
put on both parties I want to have some
governor's am I gonna have all of the
governors but I'd like to put some
representative governor's on the council
yes I would like to do a couple of them
they've all said yes so far everyone
said yes I think everybody would like to
be on that council that's a very
important to those what those still
planning to have Easter services pastors
or the pastors I didn't understand your
work okay you have a very nice voice but
it's a little bit low and you're far
back I've had talks with the pastors and
most of the pastors agree and it's very
complex subject less you know for the
others reasons they're not to go into
and most of the pastors agree that they
are better off doing what they're doing
which is distancing they feel that let's
get this over with and they want to get
back to church so badly I mean can you
imagine we have Easter Sunday and I'm
gonna be watching pastor Robert Jeffress
it's been a great guy did I tell you
he's been a great guy and I'm gonna be
watching on a laptop now a laptop is not
the same as being in his church or being
in another church it's like I didn't no
matter what you say you don't get so it
was no wonderful but I've done this for
three weeks and they've had tremendous I
let people know who it is they've had
the biggest audiences they've ever had
they have millions of people now
watching and people are really liking
what they're hearing so I'm gonna be
with on Easter pastor I don't even know
if he knows it yet but he will soon I
think you will in about two minutes
pastor Robert Jeffress and he's a
terrific guy a terrific man of guys and
I'm gonna be with pastor Robert Jeffress
on Easter I just want you guys to know
that
was our country and I'm gonna be with
him on Easter meeting I'm gonna be with
him Bert what you want a laptop Bert
doesn't sound good but it's you know
it's one of those things it cannot be
Church you know I'm not going to get
into it it cannot be Church most pastors
and most people you know of faith people
that we listen to and respect and admire
Franklin Graham is a person I have great
respect for weapon now most people will
and who's done an incredible job in New
York on Central Park where they put up
Samaritan's Purse he's done an
incredible job the son of the late great
Billy Graham his family is incredible
he's incredible
Franklin Graham the job he's doing he
recently blamed the virus on sin the guy
Trump's praising Brit blamed the virus
on sin with with incredible love and he
will tell you we're all saying we've got
to get our country cured I know there
are some pastors and ministers and
others that want to get together I would
and I have great respect for them two of
them I know but I would say first heal
I'm a Christian heal i country let's get
healed before we do this and this time
to do that will do it for hopefully the
rest of our lives
please the mercy and the comfort seem to
be under
Los Angeles New York is there any
consideration either to sending the
medical units into the cities to help
hospitals there or to moving the LTL
ships so the mercy and the comfort were
sent when projections were much higher
then I say Tony backed it up Deborah's
made the statement they said you're not
gonna need these many rooms but we
wanted to be prepared I mean you know we
had the ship they did an incredible job
where the the comfort was supposed to be
in maintenance for a period of four
weeks and they had it done in three and
a half four days and it came up and so
we had it there if there was a disaster
from the standpoint of you needed all of
it I tell you the Javits Center
Andrew will tell you we were ready to go
it's incredible the job they did but
they're they're using less beds this is
a good thing not a bad thing they're
using less Spence now javis has been
pretty busy over the last couple of days
and the death numbers are horrific but
you go back now and you're finding
they're gonna start to come down very
substantially just based on the fact
that the bed usage the number of beds
are much much less much much less so the
mercy of the Comfort were there in case
they needed them Los Angeles where you
have the one in New York we have the
other they just don't fortunately we
haven't hit numbers where they would
have knit they would have been used
they're always going to be sort of
overflow because they're on the edges
you know they're they're not as
convenient as certain places but the the
people were ready willing and able they
were ready to go they're gonna do a
great job but fortunately we don't need
just like we didn't need as many
ventilators when they were asking in New
York for 40,000 ventilators I had
experts these people I listened to them
they said you'll never need that many
and they were right in New York now has
it's and I dealt really well with mayor
de Blasio we got him a lot of
ventilators we got into a lot of
ventilators but we never felt you needed
the numbers that you were talking about
and we were right on that now with all
of that being said
we have a lot of ventilators ready to go
we have almost 10,000 in to stockpile
that 10,000 can move rapidly we can be
within 24 hours almost anywhere and
hopefully we're not gonna have to be but
it's just it's really this has been a
great military operation it hasn't all
been military because we're dealing with
great companies we have companies that
are making masks with and we're all set
up on the mass to I just told you we
have an order coming in soon
500 million masks 500 million we have
companies you know the story with GM or
3m also GM but 3m but was doing a great
job I spoke to the CEO the other day we
settled it out we had a dispute with
them and it's now well settled and I
think they're trying to show the country
something maybe me but the country
something so we've done you know I think
and not me I'm not not talking about
this country our country the people that
are doing it Army Corps of Engineers
FEMA these people sitting right here
people that we have in the back that are
watching every word that we're saying
they've done a fantastic job they really
have done a fantastic job please testing
you mentioned the impossibility of
testing the entire American public so
has what do we have to search in general
what do we have 350 million people
you're gonna do this not what I'm
getting at what I'm getting at is
priorities and dr. Burks has mentioned
how there have been priorities in
certain regional parts of the country
and I wanted to ask you specifically
about one industry in particular and
that's food processing plants is there a
priority to get testing at food
processing plants all across the country
well you're asking that because of what
happened it's a fair question to what
happened in Denver because in Denver
I've never seen I said what's going on
we're looking at this graph where
everything's looking beautiful and it's
coming down and then you got this one
spike it's I said what happened to
Denver and
many people very quickly and by the way
they were on it like so fast you
wouldn't believe it they knew every
aspect they have people going not only
testing who did you see where were you
how many people did you meet were you
out to dinner in somebody else's home
where were you where did that what did
this number of people come from how did
they are totally on it now this just
happened I just saw it this morning
I'm looking at everything smooth going
down topping out then you have this one
spike in Denver it's like where did this
come from so we'll be looking at that
and and we don't want cases like that
happening this was Western was who to
test this the kind of thing can happen
this is very complex it's a very
brilliant enemy you know it's a
brilliant enemy they develop drugs like
the antibiotics you see it antibiotics
used to solve every problem now one of
the biggest problems the world has is
the germ has gotten so brilliant that
the antibiotic can't keep up with it and
they're constantly it's a virus that's
why the antibiotic can't keep up they go
for a heart operation that's no problem
but they end up dying from from problems
you know the problems I'm talking about
if there's a whole genius to it
we're fighting not only is it hidden but
it's very smart okay it's invisible and
it's hidden but it can very smart this
camp and you see that in a case like a
Denver but you know I think we're doing
well and and there on Denver like you
wouldn't believe I came in this morning
it was a flurry I said what's going on
they said Denver so what happened in
Denver because Denver was doing pretty
well and they've got that under control
but yeah that would be a case where you
do some very big testing Peter mr.
president we learned that more than 16
million Americans filed for unemployment
over the past three weeks it's Good
Friday it's payday we are seeing
troubling paralyzing lines at food banks
around the
what do you say to those Americans in
need right this moment number one I love
them number two were working really hard
it wasn't their fault what happened
sometimes they don't do a good job and
they lose their job that's one thing
this is a case where we take the
strongest economy in the history of the
world which is what we had more people
working in the United States Peter then
ever before almost I mean look at the
numbers 160 million people almost just
short of 160 excuse me so we have the
greatest economy we've ever had and by
the way black unemployment Hispanic
unemployment Asian unemployment numbers
no ever had in virtually every way and
then you get hit like this and it's
traumatic people that had great jobs
that went out to dinner and they didn't
have any problems and take their family
they were making good salaries all of a
sudden you know you use the term cold
turkey it's cold turkey they go from
that to having no money and waiting for
their checks which are being processed
very rapidly but they still they have to
go out and look for money it's a
terrible thing all I say is we love them
we're working so hard and they're gonna
be back and I hope they're gonna be back
even stronger than before you chose not
to do a national stay-at-home order now
that you say you want to reopen parts of
the economy what authority do you have
to do that is that ultimately up to the
states to do that you know it's really
the states can do things if they want I
can override it if I want but the
National stay at home just so you
understand 95% of the country is stay at
home like as an example I was speaking
with the great governor of Texas Greg
Abbott the other day he has a stay at
home a lot of people didn't even know it
but he had to stay at home some people
reported even people like that he had a
very strong actually a very strong stay
at home 95 to 96 percent South Carolina
as you know has it which at one point a
week ago they didn't have South Carolina
another great governor McMahon
No 95% of the country is covered now the
states that aren't and again
constitutionally from a federalist
standpoint if I thought there was a
problem if I saw a state with a problem
I would absolutely demand it but they're
doing great and the states that aren't
our state said have not had a big
problem reopen right now the same way
that some of the states to shut it down
or I have a great authority if I want to
use it I would rather have the states
use it I would rather and this is so
shocking for me a lot of a lot of states
from today said reopen would not do it I
was shocked they think I do it I have
absolute authority to use it but so far
our relationship with governor's and the
job they're doing I haven't had to do it
would I do it if I saw a state that was
out of control and they didn't have to
stay at home policy I would do it in a
heartbeat
Jeff mr. president there's obviously a
lot of interest in how you're going to
make that decision what what it's a very
big decision what I don't know that I've
had a bigger decision than that when you
think of that decision somebody said
it's totally up to the president I saw
this point it's totally up and it is I
don't know that I've had a bigger
decision but I'm gonna surround myself
with the greatest minds not only the
greatest minds but the greatest minds in
numerous different businesses including
the business of politics and reason and
we're going to make a decision and
hopefully it's going to be the right
decision I will say this I want to get
it open as soon as we can we have to get
our country open Jeff say sir what
metrics you will use to make that uh the
metrics right here
oh my metrics that's all I can do I can
listen to 35 people at the end I've got
to make a decision and I didn't think of
it until yesterday I said you know this
is a big decision didn't think I want to
be guided I'm gonna be guided by them
I'm gonna be guided by our
vice-president I'm gonna make a decision
based on a lot of different opinions
some will maybe disagree and some I'd
love to see it where they don't disagree
will there be risk there's always going
to be a risk that something can flare up
there's always going to look
look at what's happening where countries
are trying to get open and there's a
flare up and they'll go but I'd like to
flip to be very localized so that we can
control it from a local standpoint
without having to close it's it's
there's always a risk this is if this is
genius that we're fighting you know
we're fighting this hidden enemy which
is genius okay it's genius the way it's
attacked what is so many changes at so
many different angles and I mean you
take a look at what's going on and the
greatest doctors in the world I think
they're close by the way but they
haven't figured it out yet
look what it's done to some people I
mean some people it's grabbed and it's a
it's a horrible it's a horrible way to
go you want to know the truth it's a
horrible and then other people that
hardly has an impact on we talked about
it sniffles it's less they don't even
know they had anything and some people I
looked at New York this morning and I
look at what's happening and the amount
of people that are dying and dying
violently dying it's it's a it's a very
tough adversary but we're gonna win are
we gonna win it we're gonna win it very
decisively I'm gonna have to make a
decision and I only hope to god that
it's the right decision
oh but I would say without question it's
the biggest decision I've ever had to
make the models that I understand them
are based on social distancing
through May is that correct and if you
were to open the economy on May first or
sometime during that month would that
impact the models in terms of the deaths
that you beautiful good so the model the
IHM ii model does state that it's
through May every month we've had these
model discussions haven't we for weeks
now so the models are informed by the
data and you can see how much that model
has shifted on the amazing work of the
American people so I think that's what
we're evaluating right now remember when
when I talked yesterday I've been in
public health a long time I have never
except for Ebola where we worked very
closely with the communities about
specific issues
let me just mute her briefly the model
has just been updated while we've been
doing this it now says today is the peak
the model has just been updated the peak
has been moved up two days with another
reduction in peak deaths and the total
deaths have moved up by about a thousand
so the model has been updated as over
the last 15 minutes it now says today is
the peak today is the peak according to
the model mister Ron's no communal
eating that was thought to be a very big
issue and many of the other cultures
that went through this virus so the
models continue to evolve based on the
impact and so therefore it makes it very
difficult to interpret each component of
social distancing and which ones are
absolutely critical now there's a way to
do that in multivariate analysis
potentially and I want to I want
everyone to understand there are states
that are testing there are states that
are doing contact tracing so I mean it's
I think sometimes we get and we look at
what New York is doing and Detroit we
forget that there's a Utah and New
Mexico and a North and South Dakota and
a whole series of states that have been
doing testing and contact tracing and
I've been testing it rates higher than
that
capita rate that we all have discussed
so we're looking at that what did they
do
where are the most vulnerabilities where
are the outbreaks most likely to occur
that's why I've been talking about
nursing homes because we do believe that
there's a relationship between age and
seriousness of disease not to say that
there can't be young people with serious
disease but proportionally it's a
smaller piece with serious disease and
so when you have that kind of spectrum
where the older and the more complicated
the higher the severity you get the
impression that there may be more
asymptomatic in younger age groups and
that's where the antibody test comes in
so when you put all these pieces
together you're trying to understand
where's where would be the first signals
so we have surveillance out there right
now with the CDC's influenza like
illness I hope you're all tracking that
it is showing these small changes I
think we can believe in that is their
surveillance tool married with their
syndromic piece giving us the insight
about where to test and then where to
proactively test and nursing homes and
other vulnerable groups because that has
been the signal in a series of the
states that have very very low
prevalence and incidence of disease so
that's the kind of factors we're putting
all together to really define the best
way forward and we have superb roadmaps
I hope you all have seen them there's
been about six different roadmaps -
opening the people have put online and
again there's no literature that you
need I said well we did this 20 years
ago and what really worked there's there
isn't that there's brilliant Public
Health people giving us their insights
or the question is
because those are the models you've been
using if you do go with opening up
starting to open up the economy again
our May first doesn't that lead to more
deaths well look at how much it changed
with mitigation and now we're looking at
those state by state and there's some
states in there that are still in
contact tracing so we're looking at the
impact of that model what that model
predicted based on the type of contact
tracing less mitigation more contact
raising are we are you getting what I'm
talking about
okay so there are states that didn't
stay-at-home orders but we're doing
contract rate contact tracing
I'm from outbreaks so we're looking at
them and how they have done and we're
looking at certainly what's happened in
the big metro areas and we're
integrating all of that data together to
make a plan going forward so I can't
tell you because look at how much the
model has changed in just a week
remember just a week ago it was 80,000
now it's 60,000 so and the curves I'm
sure you're all watching it the curves
of getting much broader confidence
intervals there is still the dotted line
but the confidence intervals around the
dotted line are getting bigger when you
see that you know the model has a bit of
an instability and so that's why Tony
and I based a lot of our decision and
discussion on cases and what physically
is happening in that county and that
state at the same time not ignoring the
models but integrating the models is one
piece of our thought process do you want
to come up here and say what you think
about my I just want to say that you
know you talked about couldn't it lead
to death
meaning you open up could lead to death
and you're right but you know what
staying at home leads to death also
and it's very traumatic for this country
but staying at home if you look at
numbers that leads to a different kind
of death perhaps but it leads to death
also so it's a very big decision as I
say it's the biggest decision I'll ever
make all right we'll do a couple more
we'll go
Thank You mr. president um before you
came out here you said when the last
people that you talked to was Governor
Cuomo fish and at his news conference
today he said that he was asking you to
use the defense production act to
require companies to make more tasks to
streamline testing is that something
that you would consider because you've
considered it with ventilator you know
the other side seems to keep using that
and I have used it you know I've enacted
it you do know and I've used it some
people thought viciously just ask a
couple of companies if you want you can
just look up the names and I'm surprised
that he would have said that we actually
have great tests we have others under
development
you don't need full testing as the
doctors have been talking about ad
nauseam so I would be surprised that he
would have said that meaning it that way
if he if he did I'd have a much
different type answer go ahead we talked
about testing yeah we did talk about
testing and one of the things I did was
I put the two doctors in charge of that
call I said you know what Andrew I have
two very talented people standing here
we're getting ready to go on let me put
them and let me have them talk to you
and they talked to him really at length
and I think by the time they finished he
understood what he was what we were
saying he understood it very clearly
okay okay well the question please
you've talked a lot this week about
holding the World Health Organization
responsible for its response to the
corona virus I'm curious if you've given
any more thought to holding China
financially responsible for the part
that it played and the economic toll
that it's taking on the American people
yeah I understand the question very well
nobody has done to China or treated
China as strongly as I have
he's the word strongly as you know
you've reported on it billions and
billions of dollars is flowing into our
treasury because of what i've done with
china
I think it's a very sad thing that
happened and I think if people knew
including the World Health Organization
and I do believe they knew but they
didn't want to tell the world and we're
gonna get to the bottom of it and we'll
have reports on all of this and we are
we are not happy about it but I wanted
to leave the World Health or later and I
can tell you that we're constantly in
touch with China we're talking to China
and we've expressed how we felt we're
not happy about it we're not happy about
it at all Kristen okay one or two more
yeah this president we hear from a lot
of people who see these briefings as
sort of happy talk briefings and they'll
happy talk today and some of the
officials paint a rosy picture of what
is happening around the country if you
look at some of these questions do we
have enough mass know we have enough
tests know do we have enough PPE no why
would you say that we have enough
answers yes I think the answer is yes
who said no to them I'm saying listener
you're saying no but who said yeah we
but your ask but do we have enough
master yes sir as we hear from no one
say this you said do we have enough
masks yes do we have enough tests yes
plus we're developing new - do we have
enough do we have enough ventilators yes
do we have enough hospital beds yes
we've built 20,000 hospital beds we have
enough hospital beds
go ahead Jim let's go well what do you
say - you mean you watch the coverage
you know a nice-lookin a lot of cover
well a lot of it space don't know a lot
of it's fake there's really just when
the doctors think I'm the governor wire
the governor's report out without tests
we don't have a knife as me yet
depending on your air they always say
that because otherwise you're not gonna
put them on let me just taste them the
governors have said last night they had
a group of Governors 14 governors they
were together someplace and they said
it's been unbelievable what's happened
we've been totally responsive
ventilators everyone has the ventilators
they need to a point where we're getting
calls from foreign countries saying you
have all the ventilators can we get some
can and we're gonna try and help some of
these countries these people have done
and
credible job this is not happy talk
maybe it's happy tuft for you it's not
happy talk for me we're talking about
death we're talking about the greatest
economy in the world one day I have to
close it off and we did the right thing
because maybe it would have been 2
million people died instead of whatever
that final number will be which could be
60 could be 70 could be 75 could be 55
thousands of people of that there's
nothing happy about it Jim this is sad
talk this is the saddest these are the
sad and these are the saddest news
conferences that I've ever had I don't
like doing them you know why because I'm
talking about death I'm talking about
taking the greatest economy ever created
we had the greatest numbers we've ever
had in almost every aspect of of
economics from employment to companies
look at the airlines they were having
the best year now all of a sudden we
have to save them okay there's no happy
talk to him this is the real deal and
I've got to make the biggest decision of
my life
mmm and I've only started thinking about
that I mean you know I've made a lot of
big decisions over my thinking of the
press conference Trump said it might be
the biggest decision of his presidency
he then went to it is the biggest
decision of my presidency and now he's
gone - it's the biggest decision of my
life look at how he gets himself going
visible job I watched this morning and I
watched a certain Network and it wasn't
Fox and you a doctor saying that we've
done an incredible job you just read off
these no no no well we have ventilators
we have equipment we have beds
how about beds I mean Governor Cuomo
just told me a little while ago he's got
plenty of beds in fact I have a hard
time filling Javits Center we built them
two thousand nine hundred beds so that's
not a fair question you're stabilizing
meds you're talking about reusing PPE oh
no excuse me
we have masks we have everything and we
were trying to get ready for the surge
and a lot of people said it will never
happen Debra said it you'll never need
that many beds they said we needed
40,000 ventilators 40 thousands like
building a car beneath a 40,000
- laters people said I felt it - you'll
never need that many guess what we have
tremendous we have with the envy of the
world in terms of ventilators Germany
would like some France would like some
we're gonna help countries out Spain
needs him desperately Italy needs them
desperately Mexico needs them
desperately he asked me last night would
it be possible to get 10,000 ventilators
within a short period of time I'll be
able to help out Mexico no Jim just the
opposite of your question it's not no no
no it's yes yes yes we're in great shape
and you know what what's happening now
is those numbers are horrible but take a
look at the number of beds we have beds
available all over new york new york
really being the epicenter new york new
york has experienced something that has
been absolutely horrific
I saw Hart's Island yesterday I saw
those people being buried yesterday
fortunately we have the beds and you can
speak to mayor de Blasio you can speak
to Governor Cuomo people are people
can't even believe the job we've done
they can't even believe it and I give
tremendous credit to the military
there's been a military operation with
private people but wait a minute
wait wait I give tremendous credit to
our military to the Army Corps of
Engineers to FEMA to these people the
job they've done is incredible and you
shouldn't be asking for that kind of a
question Jim honestly country good ok
look I really don't believe you
shouldn't be asking that kind of a
question you should say you know what
it's been really incredible what's been
a half an hour Jim nobody's asking what
I'm telling the reporters what questions
to ask what governor we have more tests
than anybody in the world we have every
moszeter we have virtually every country
in the world calling us asking us how do
we get these tests that you have your
testing is the best in the world how do
we get it that can't they have done a
fantastic job and when you ask a
question like that it's very insulting
to a lot of great people ok one more
place
but president you may have seen how
Sweden has responded to the pandemic the
schools are open bars and restaurants
are open Sweden's differently do you do
you regret not following that approach
is that approach work I did we do the
follow that approach and if we did
follow that approach I think we might
have 2 million people dead and Sweden is
having a lot of difficulty yeah you know
look I'm very friendly with the
leadership in Sweden they took a
different approach they're a very
disciplined country to start off with
but they did take a different and you
know other places tried it
UK tried it the herd approach ok heard
and they tried it and you saw what
happened in UK it set him back a lot a
lot of time it's been you know they
having a tough time other countries have
tried it and Sweden is suffering greatly
I mean Sweden's suffering greatly if we
did the herd if we went with the herd as
they say we would have had potentially I
mean you see that the charts nobody
knows nobody will ever know fortunately
because we're gonna be substantially
less than the minimum I certainly hope
unless something happens that would be
tragic so they had a minimum number if
we did if one of the reasons was so far
below that numbers because nobody
thought the American people could be so
disciplined nobody thought it was
possible and I guess when they watched
us appear every day and they watched
other people and they listened to their
representatives and governors nobody
thought that the American people could
be so disciplined they've been
unbelievable and because of that so you
have a minimum number of a hundred
thousand and then you had the 2.2 number
that if we did nothing if we did just
kept working and everybody go to where
people would be dropping dead on the
subways no if we would have lost a
million people take the 2.2 million and
cut it in half make it cut it in more
than half make it a million people ok
now take that number and cut it and make
it 500,000 people
that's if we did nothing right it's
unacceptable it's too many people so we
have
spent more money on stimulus who cares
by comparison
you take 2.2 you cut it in half you cut
it in half you cut it in if you keep
cutting it in half I don't care what
nobody choose five hundred thousand four
hundred thousand well we're gonna have
we were talking 50 sixty six cata movie
stage maybe but if we would have done
what one country tried and it has been
very tough for them you know that very
very nasty very tough but if we would
have done that here and again you got to
remember UK tried it and I was a little
surprised and I watch it they were going
about what two weeks and they said we
got a stop because it was then we're
gonna have a whole country infected so
with all of that being said we got to
get back to work we got to get we got to
get our country open but we could have
lost two million people we could have
lost 1 million people we could have lost
a half a million people if we would have
lost 500,000 people
now I'll say this also from the
standpoint of being president and vice
president and we're up there and we're
doing that hurt and we're gonna bullet
through it do you honestly think people
like Jim and yourself and other people
would have Jeff would have put up with
it as people are dying all over they
would have said this man is crazy
because the numbers Tony at a minimum
would have been many many times greater
than the numbers were talking about so
I'm very honored by our decisions all of
us we talk about it all the time I said
you want to let him just you just write
it you just write it right through we
would have lost potentially millions of
people now it would have been
unsustainable it would have been
impossible to do and the American people
have been so disciplined it's been my
honor to be their president I've said it
before I'll say it again I'll say it
always it's been it's been my great
honor to have been their president and I
have a big decision coming up and I only
hope to god that it's the right decision
but it'll be based on the input from a
lot of very talented talented people
very smart people
and people that love our country thank
you all very much thank you Donald Trump
rapping today another completely
dissembling erratic and rambling press
conference before you go one small
request I did no membership pitches
today you might have noticed my only
request is if you are in the area where
you are not down to your last dollar
throw us a dollar on patreon you see we
are 20 out of 50 patrons there
patreon.com slash david pakman show I
saw them rolling in as people were
talking I don't want anybody's last
dollar but we did lose almost 400
supporters in March not to the I mean
they died I mean they just had to stop
donating I want I need to be careful
about the language a record for us
losing four hundred supporters we've
lost several dozen so far in April so I
don't want anybody's last dollar we're
all in this together
but consider a pledge as little as one
dollar at patreon.com slash david pakman
show twenty people have done it we would
love to get to fifty and we will
continue to follow I don't know if we're
expecting a briefing tomorrow or if
we're expecting a briefing on Sunday we
just don't know importantly very
important while this press conference
was going on the IHM ii model was
updated
they now have today as the peak today
expecting 1983 deaths the actual
official number today is 16 34 expecting
1983 of course it could be anywhere
between five hundred and fifty five
hundred the actual number they say today
is the peak day and it will be a very
slow decline we will still be at fifteen
hundred deaths per day in another ten
days we will still be at a thousand
deaths per day on on April 30th so we've
still got a long way to go this is kovat
19 dot health data org a slight uptick
in the expected number of deaths in wave
one remember this is wave one from
60,000 to 61 thousand
and that is the latest update let me say
thank you to Gabe who is new patron
number 21 today thanks Gabe very much
appreciated
we we did this yesterday did patreon
instead of memberships and a lot of a
lot of interesting and exciting people
came in and that is always very much
appreciated so this is the update this
update took place while today's press
conference was going on we will see
where we are by Monday imagine imagine
if by Monday we start to see a decline
in the number of deaths as you can see
here cases have sort of plateaued we've
been right around this 30k a day area
and deaths three very bad days in a row
essentially the same with slight
declines and we will we will continue to
track that and this is the question are
we doing it are we are we getting there
I want to say thanks to Kevin Gustafson
whose new patron number 22 today I also
want to say thank you to Sean fro Lander
who is new patron number 23 today very
much appreciate that we we actually we
took a hit on patrons as well towards
the end of March listen I get it
everybody's everybody's struggling and
everybody's doing what they can I want
to also say thanks to Sarah Blas who is
new patron number 24 today thank you
Sarah very much appreciate that of
course the beauty of patreon is you can
pledge as much as you want but you can
pledge as little as a dollar that's a
very very exciting thing thanks to
everybody who joined me today I'll be
back with you very soon briefings we've
got clips coming out and all of that
exciting stuff
you